A következő vendégem Albert Orsolya,
színművésznő lesz, akivel mindenféle
izgalmas dolgokról szeretnék
beszélgetni, mint például hogyan indult
a pályáján, mivel is jár a színészi
szakma, kétgyerekes családaként, hogyan
tudja egyeztetni ezt a a színészi
szakmát és az anyaságát, valamint egy
számomra nagyon izgalmas és új dologról
a versekről fogunk beszélgetni. Úgyhogy
tartsatok velünk.
Köszöntök minden kedves hallgatót. A mai
nap Orsiival fogok beszélgetni Albert
Orsolya
színművésznővel, és egy csomó izgalmas
témát
készítettem számunkra, hogy mikről
fogunk beszélgetni, de mindenesetre
először is üdvözöllek a stúdiónkban.
Szia Szabolcs. Szeretettel köszöntök én
is mindenkit. Igen, hát az előbb
megkérdeztem úgy titokban, hogy izgul-e
így a felvétel előtt. Azt mondta, hogy
egy kicsit izgul. Ez fog oldódni,
gondolom. De hogy lehetséges, hogy egy
színművésznő, akinek nap mint nap próbái
vannak, és több 100 ember előtte fellép,
hogy hogy tudsz még izgulni? Szerintem
az legtöbbször rossz is, hogyha az ember
nem izgul, bármilyen ilyen helyzet
adódik. Másrészt pedig az izgalom is úgy
van, hogyha magad odateszed ezekbe a
dolgokba, és minél többször találkozol
vele, egy idő után csökken. Tehát, hogy
azért mondtam azt, hogy izgulok ebben az
esetben, mert podcast felvételem eddig
nem volt még olyan sok. Ellenben a
színházban esténként valójában tényleg
sokszor fellépek, de ott is mindig van
bennem egy izgalom színpadra lépés
előtti pillanatokban. És nagyon érdekes,
hogy tényleg ahogy bemegyek a színpadra,
vagy ezt így többen a kollégáimmal
elbeszéljük, ez így hirtelen
eltűnik. A az egyik kérdésem az volt,
emlékszem a beszédtechnikám pont erre
rákérdeztem, de ez ennél aktuálisabb nem
is lehetne most számomra, hogy a a mai
nap nem éreztem túl jól magam. Reggel
felkeltem és a derekhamis fájt és kicsit
úgy meg vagyok hűlve, dünnyögök is egy
picit.
Úgyhogy így az első kérdés ilyenkor
bennem az, hogyha ha felveszel egy
kedves életteli feminin szerepet, ami
amelyik tele van vidámsággal és azt kell
eljátszodd este, de neked semmi kedved
nincs, mert fáj ahassad hány ingered
van, és
és az egész világgal most legszívesebben
tartanál egy szünetet, akkor ilyen
ilyenkor ez hogy működik?
Egyrészt addig megerőlteted magad
nyilván, amíg beérsz a színházba, mert
addig azt érzed, hogy tényleg most mást
csinálnál, otthon lennél, feküdnél, de
abban a pillanatban, ahogy beírtél és
elkezdesz átalakulni, és érdekes itt
maga az átalakulás is a színészeknél,
hogy nem az van, hogy bemész és egyből
mondjuk a kapusszobától belépsz a
színpadra, és ilyennek kell lenni,
pengének kell lenni, hanem hanem van egy
rituálé, van egy folyamat, ami segít
téged abban, hogy átalakuljál és azzá
válj, áll, aki belépik perceken belül a
színpadra a közönség elé. Tehát, hogy át
átvedeljél úgymond azzá a szereplővé,
azzá a karakteré karakterré. És
és ez a folyamat nagyon segít abban,
tehát hogyha bemész, mondjuk fáj még a
hasad, nincsen kedved, két perce vagy 20
percre rá már rajtad van a smink, már
azt érzed, hogy egy picit nem te vagy
már egy egy kicsit bennebb vagy az
előadás karakterébe, kicsit jobban
beleléptél, és ahogy felveszed a
ruháját, meg meg ahogy egyre közeledik a
pillanat, amikor el kell kezdeni, akkor
érdekes módon valahogy megszűnnek ezek a
ezek a bizony bizonyos rosszul létek,
fájdalmak, és nyilván ez ennek köze van
ahhoz, hogy az adrenalin egyre nő a
szervezetünkbe, a stresszhormonok és és
maga az, hogy belépünk, annak van egy
olyan flowja meg az előadás menetének,
amiben elfeledkezel arról, hogy hogy
neked most bármit is fájna, hiszen te
most az a másik ember vagy, vagy ha nem
is az vagy, de hogy hogy valahogy
sikerül ezt mindig elfelejteni.
Szerintem ugyanúgy van, mint a
sportolóknál, hogy mondjuk láttunk
olyat, hogy egy futó egy nagy maratonban
kiment a bokája, végignyomja, ahogy
beesik a startba, utána érzi azt, hogy
ez mennyire fáj, és lehet, hogy óriási
volt a probléma, de nem vette észre,
mert egyszerűen a versenyszellem, vagy
minket is az az izgalom, ami a ami a
színészeknek a az alapja, az annyira
fenn tart, hogy elnyom minden más
fájdalomérzetet, hozz kedv Dors más
karakteré. Ilyenkor amúgy a másik
karakternek a fájdalmát felveszed? Tehát
hogy amikor tegyük fel egy egy drámát
játszol és tegyük fel tényleg valami
olyan karaktert játszol aki tele van
fájdalommal. Ezeket átéled ezeket a
fájdalmakat? Igen, igen, átélem. És
nagyon sokáig nem is értettem. Még
mindig azt gondoltam, vagy olyan voltam,
hogy egy előadás után is a tapsrendet
úgy éreztem, hogy még az olyan visszás
lenne, hogyha egy mondjuk egy dráma vagy
egy tragédia után én, mint Orsi kimennék
és vigyorognék. Igen, mert akkor azt k
azt azt értettem, vagy éreztem akkor,
hogy azt közvetítem az embereknek, hogy
hogy ez ez csak egy játékot. És közben
nemrég jöttem rá pár éve, mondjuk, hogy
pont ezt kell nekem közvetíteni, mert
ugyanúgy saját magam is le kell tegyem
ezt a szerepet, mondjuk például akár a
Linán szépe előadás kapcsán, ahol
megölöm az anyámat. Tehát én is az
előadás végére a tapsrendre el kell
odajussak, hogy ez nem az igazság volt,
nem ölném meg az anyámat, de azt a
nézőknek is ezt a könnyebbséget meg kell
adjam, hogy benne voltunk ebben a
történetben, de de ez ez ennyi volt. Ez
átmosott minket, de de megy tovább az
élet. Megyek, leveszem, ugyanúgy
visszafele is működik a rituálé, a
metamorfózis, ahogy ahogy visszavedlek
emberré. És nagyon fontos ilyenkor
például az, hogy hazasétáljak. És az a
bár közel lakunk a színházhoz, de az a
5-10 perc, amikor a levegőn
kiszellőzteted a fejed, az szerintem
elengedhetetlen minden színész életében.
Ühüm. Akkor ez tanulható, ez a felvedlés
és levedlés, tehát hogy egy idő után
bele tud jönni az ember abba, hogy hogy
ez ez egy szerep volt és egy célja van.
Így van. Sőt, szerintem akkor jó, hogyha
amikor már ezt megtanultad. Ühüm. Annak
ellenére, hogy én is mindig így azt
hittem, hogy akkor ösztönösen bele kell
szökni és mindent magadból kijátszani.
Persze van ez a része is, ami ami
terápia és feljönnek bennem is a dolgok,
ezért szeretek belehelyezkedni. Tehát én
mindig arra törekszem, hogy éljem át a
történetet, és ne eltartsam magamtól.
Tehát hogyha azt gondolom, hogy ez a
szereplő, amit csinál, például én ezt
soha nem tenném meg, akár a keresztényi
értékrendem miatt, akár ilyen vagy
olyan
etikátlanságként fogom ezt fel, de még
mégis azt gondolom, hogy meg kell
keresnem nekem benne azt, hogy ezt miért
tette. És érdekes, hogy minden minden
egyes előadásban minden szereplőnek
megvan a miértje,
és ezért érdekes és komplex folyamat
például egy rendezőnek lenni. Mert egy
rendező úgy kell megrendezze az egész
előadást, úgy kell színpadra állítsa azt
a drámát, hogy mindenkinek meglegyen az
igazsága. Ühüm. Tehát, hogy átlássa az
összes karakternek a motivációját, miért
miért mit tesz pontosan, és az egész
történetet ledesztilálni csak a
lényegre. Olyan karaktereket is el
szoktál vállalni, akivel nem értesz
egyet, vagy pontosabban ez volt a
kérdésem, hogy van-e olyan karakter,
akit nem tudnál eljátszani? Az az
érzésed, hogy akármennyire megkapod a
miértét, képtelen lennél eljátszani?
Nem, egyelőre úgy érzem, hogy nincs.
Sőt, a minél távolabbi nagy kihívások
sokkal jobban foglalkoztatják a a
színészt is. Hm. Tehát vala valami
olyan, ami még nem volt. Tehát mit
visszaemlékszem akár a migránsok
előadásunkban, például egy politikust
játszottam, egy férfi politikust. A a
migránsok előadásnak pont az volt a a
lényege, a migráció kellős közepén hozta
hozta létre ezt az udvarhelyi társulat.
És nagyon érdekes volt egyébként egy
Mátéi Visnieg darab, nagyon jó, és
minden szemszögből megvizsgálta a
migráció kérdését, és én pont a
politikus voltam, tehát magamtól
életemben nem választottam volna ezt a
kategóriát, mert annyira távol áll tőem
az egész politika, mint nagyon-nagyon
távol. Tehát
és érdekes volt, hogy hogy valahogy
ennek is megkapni azt a miértét, meg
hogy az egész világunkban ez is egy
összetevő. És ezek nagyon érdekesek,
hogy hogy olyan színesek vagyunk, de
hogy mindenki valamit hozzátesz ahhoz,
hogy ilyen ilyen És azáltal, hogy ezt a
politikust eljátszottad, többet meg
tudtál a politikáról is. Tehát hogy mi a
dinamikájának a Igen, igen, igen, igen.
vagy hogy mennyire fontos a politikai
korrektség, vagy hogy hogy mit jelent
az, hogy úgy mondani valamit, hogy
számomra lényegi dolgot nem mondok, de
folyamatosan beszélek politikai korrekt
módon, és közben el van rejtve a lényeg,
és és hogy ezzel mennyire lehet
manipulálni.
Onnan tudjuk, hogy az a podcast jó lesz
amúgy, hogy nekem később volt tervem
feltenni egy kérdést, amit most fogok
feltenni, mert egyszerűen már
odakerültünk. Az egyik sztereotíp képem
az a főleg a női színésznőkről amiatt,
mert mert a nyugati média valószínűleg
így kondicionált engem, az az, hogy hogy
vigyáznom kell a azokkal a
színésznőkkel, akik csinosak, akik
vonzóak, mert pont emiatt, hogy képesek
felvedleni valamilyen bőrt magukra és
levedleni, emiatt nem bízhatok meg
bennük, mert mert nem tudom, hogy melyik
az igazi oldala, hogy
és és még azt hozzátenném, hogy veled
most már sokszor találkoztam a
beszédtechnika képzéseden is részt
vettem, most már több interakcióm van és
felépült egy bizalom, de előtte nyilván
azt a sztereotip képet rád vetítettem,
mert nyilván hogy hogy a bizalomra
szükség van ahhoz, hogy hogy egy szép nő
szét tudja szakítani a férfiakat. Ez egy
hatalom, egy igazi hatalom a a kezébe
egy egy nőnek. És
hogy hogy ezt te hogy látod, hogy ez a
képességed, hogy fel tudsz vedleni és le
tudsz vedleni bőröket, ez mitől hol van
ennek az etikai határa pontosan? És hog
hogyan bíznak meg benned a
környezetedben, hogy most éppen nem
színészi szerepet játszol, mert nyilván,
hogy aznek eszköz, tehát mint eszközt
használod és egy célra használod, de
hogy járjuk akkor körbe ezt a kérdést,
megalapozott-e szerinted ez a
sztereotípképem? Tehát hogyha most így a
színészi környezetedre nézel, akkor
mennyire jellemző az, hogy ezt helyesen
használják ezt a képességet a a színész
nő társaid?
Azt kell mondanom, bár szeretném azt
mondani, hogy abszolút nem, mégis azt
érzem, hogy nagy részben nem, de mindig
van egy egy kicsi rész amennyiben igen.
De itt nem is annyira a színésznőségre
utalnék, hanem hanem eleven nőként
szerintem van az a kategória, aki szeret
visszaélni azzal, hogy nő. Szereti ezt
kitenni és ezzel hatalmat gyakorolni a
férfiakra.
Én azt gondolom, hogy ez nem függ össze,
és és teljesen azt érzem, hogy ez egy
emberi történet. Ühüm.
Tehát valószínűleg valahonnan indul az
egész, de mondjuk, hogyha azt mondom
neked, hogy miért nem félsz egy
postástól, hogy hogy a leveledet
felbontja és
elolvassa, akkor ő is ugyanezzel
visszaélhet az ő
és ez most csak így hirtelen közben
jutott eszembe pont egy jelenleg
olvasott könyvem kapcsán, amiben így ez
történik, mert elkezdtem gondolkodni,
hogy bármilyen szak szakterülen végül is
vissza lehetne ezzel élni, de valójában
tényleg a színésznőkkel kapcsolatban van
ez az előítélet.
Én nyilván a saját magamról tudok.
Valószínűleg én ilyen antiszínésznő
vagyok ilyen szempontból, mert tudok
ilyesmiről is, hogy bizony az egyetemen
nagyobb kolléga, aki most is a szakmában
van, veszített egy ládasőrt emiatt, hogy
én amikor felkerültem, akkor már a a
párommal és a férjemmel együtt voltunk,
és hogy akkor voltak ilyen olyan
fogadások, hogy úgy is be lehet engem
cserkészni, de hogy ez nem sikerült, és
utána én nem tudtam nyilván távkapcsolat
volt, ugye? távkapcsolat volt. Igen, én
akkor nem tudtam erről, de utána egyik
alkalommal, amikor találkoztunk, odajött
és mondta, hogy ő vesztett miattam egy
láda sőrör, de hogy ő ennek igazából
örül. Úgyhogy én emiatt mondom, hogy
nyilván saját magamról tudok beszélni.
Nem éreztem soha azt, hogy ezzel
visszaélnék. meg nekem onnantól, hogy
hazamegyek, vagy hogy itt veled
beszélgetek, bennem soha nem az van,
hogy én színésznőként vagyok itt, vagy
vagyok az élet különböző területein. Nem
színésznőként kérek egy kávét, hanem én
orsiként kérek, és teljesen más dolog
az, amikor felmegyek a színpadra, és ott
van egy feladatom, amit kértek tőlem,
hogy azt végrehajtsam. Ühüm. Egy
gyanítom, hogy akkor ez egy olyanféle
hatalom, mint a harcművészet, hogy abban
a pillanatban, amikor etikus, akkor
probléma nélkül tudja használni az, aki
egész életében ezt gyakorolta, de amikor
nem etikus, akkor akkor egyszerűen meg
tudja állítani magába ezeket a két,
tehát hogyha valaki felmérgesíti, akkor
egyből nem azzal kezdi, hogy eltöri a
kezét a másiknak, hanem tudja magát
kontrollálni. Valami hasonló lehet,
akkor gondolom a te kezedben is ez az
eszköz, hogy tudnád, hogy el tudnád
játszani, de nem teszed meg. És és
legalábbis én ezt tapasztaltam amúgy
veled, hogy abszolút biztonságban
vagyok. Én én én amúgy elég jól kiérzem,
hogyha valaki színészkedik izé ebbe mást
játszik, mint ami valójában. De amikor a
beszédtechnikára jártam hozzád, akkor
beszédtechnikai szakemberré váltál, és
amikor személyesen beszélgettünk, akkor
Orsival beszélgetek, és a színészi
oldalat egyszer-kétszer láttam, mint
néző, és akkor pedig megszűntél tényleg
valóban számomra orsinak lenni.
Úgyhogy és akkor visszatérve az utolsó
részé eznek a kérdésnek, akkor te inkább
a a a kevesekhez tartozol, vagy azt
mondhatod, hogy inkább az a kevés, aki
ezzel visszaél?
Én reménykedem, hogy hogy ez csak egy
olyan sztereotípia, aminek nem
feltétlenül mindig valóság alapon áll.
Úgyhogy remélem, hogy a kevesek keves
kevesen vannak, akik ezzel visszaélnek.
Meg szeretném hinni. Én azt is gondolom,
hogy mindig mindig onnan izgalmas egy
történet, onnan izgalmas egy kapcsolat
egy emberrel, hogyha annak veszélyei
vannak. És a veszély onnan tud lenni,
hogyha te beleenged magad, hogyha te nem
egy falat építesz fel, nem
úgy úgy fordulsz valakihez, hogy közben
meg megvannak a stratégiáid. Hát abban a
pillanatban mihegy szerepet játszol, egy
falat felhúzol és akkor és akkor nem
érdekel a másik, nem vagy nyitott a
másik, mert ha a másik megbánt, akkor
valójában azt a szemét bántotta meg,
akit én eljátszottam, ami amúgy sem
valós.
Nehéz ezt egyébként nehéz nehéz eljutni
odáig, hogy
hogy ne ne akard megjátszani magad, de
itt itt nem annyira arról van szó már,
amit te kérdeztél, hanem akár an annak
apropóján gondolom ezt, amit mondtál,
hogy hogy nem egy beszédtechnika tanár
vagyok, vagy nem ez vagyok, vagy az
vagyok. És ezt mindig ezzel is kezdtem,
akár a diákokkal is a kurzust, hogy hogy
nem vagyok én senki nem mindenható. Én
megpróbálok a
szakterületemen komolyan venni, és és
azon egy egy picit
fejlődni, és megmutatni azt, amit én már
tudok. De de soha nem állítom azt, hogy
én vagyok a a legjobb színész, én vagyok
a
legjobb tréner, én vagyok a legjobb
anya.
semmit és folyamatosan nyilván azon
dolgozok magamban, hogy minél jobb
legyek, de hogy folyamatosan mégis
elégedetlen vagyok magammal. Hm. Ez ez
akkor jellemző rád, hogy hogy
elégedetlen vagy magaddal. Igen, igen.
Én nagyon, azt hiszem, nagyon imposztors
szindrómás vagyok, úgyhogy ahogy a nők
általában a nők nagy része, most amikor
készültem a a nőnapi előadásomra, akkor
többek között ez is kiderült, hogy hogy
sokkal sokkal jobban jellemző ránk a
szorongás, az imposztorszindró, az hogy
nem nincsen önbizalmunk, mint mondjuk a
férfitársainkra. Ühüm.
azért azért nem is semmi az a teher,
amit egy nő kell manapság viseljen.
Tehát, hogy az a sok szé sokféle szerep,
hogy anyaként helytálljon, hogy
szakemberként helytálljon, mint nő, mint
egyén helytálljon, azért azért nem. És
és persze tehát a női rész is tovább
tagolódik, tehát hogy olyan elvár
irreális elvárásaink vannak a nőkkel
szemben, hogy hogyan nézzenek ki, hogyan
viselkedjenek, hogy hogy nem is csoda,
hogy ilyen
szempontból én is erre tippelnék, hogy a
nők azért azért sokkal inkább érzik ezt
magukon, ezt a terhet, hogy hogy
imposztorok lehetnek. Amúgy te miért
választottad ezt a szakmát? Mikor volt
az, amikor így magadban megfogalmaztad,
hogy hogy színésznő szeretnél lenni?
Valójában arra emlékszem, hogy mindig ez
volt, tehát pont gondolkodtam, hogy de
mi más lehettem volna, vagy így már
kicsi korom óta azt éreztem, valójában
gondolom, hogy elkaphatott egyszer egy
flow, hogy megtanítottak a szüleim egy
verset nekem, és akkor én azt elmondtam,
és ez tetszhetett, és én azt éreztem,
hogy vá, hogyha ez tetszik, akkor nekem
ezzel dolgom van. De hogy így a az
egyetem alatt, vagy sőt már a a
középiskola alatt is így soha nem láttam
magam, hogy én például orvos legyek,
vagy mérnök legyek, vagy tehát az az
egyetlen dolog, ami ezen kívül úgy
mindig izgatott, az maga a szervezés meg
a a gondolkodás, hogy akkor hogy lehetne
jó dolgokat véghez vinni, olyan
dolgokat, amik amik még nem voltak
mindig, ez a még nem ez a ez az
izgalmasnak a keresése, a potenciálnak
agen a meglátni a jövőben rejlő
potenciált, hogy ezt is lehetne
csinálni, meg azt is lehetne csinálni.
Így ahogy utána néztem, hogy mikkel
foglalkoztál, abszolút jellemző volt
akkor a középiskolában is, hogy
egyfolytában agyaltál így a a most nem
jut eszembe, diáktanácsnak voltál a
tagja. Igen. A diáktanácsnak az elnöke.
Jó, nem is tagja. Igen. És Sándor volt
az alelnöke úgyhogy jó páros jó kis
párost alkottatok. És miket csináltatok?
Vissza tudsz emlékezni? Mik voltak a
legnagyobb dolgok, amik így a amire még
büszke is vagy? Arra emlékszem nagyon,
hogy akkor már úgy a gimi diáknapok
picit olyan leszálló pályán volt. Tehát
így a tanárok is, ahogy ezt
visszajelezték, volt például mindig a
szejkére kirándulás, de egyre kevesebben
mentek, és azt például nagyon sikerült
akkor nem nekem, hanem a csapatnak
együtt
fellendíteni. És nagyon jó volt azt
látni, hogy vagyunk egy páran, akik
tudjuk, hogy ez a diáknapokban van
potenciál, és ez lehet jobb. És akkor
nem tudom, onnantól elkezdve, hogy
vittük be a lepedőket és nagyba kiírtuk
a lepedőkre, hogy gimi diáknapok és
kiraktuk az ablakba odáig, hogy gimi
rádiót csináltunk, vagy Valentin napon
egy ilyen nagy szívet felvittünk, és
akkor ott lehetett fotózkodni a
pároknak. Rengeteg olyan dolgot
megvalósítottunk. Mi találtuk ki azt,
hogy hogy legyen egy ilyen kis kávézónk
ezen a gimi diáknapos héten, és akkor
egy osztályt átalakítottunk ilyen
kávézónak, ahová lehetett menni,
rendhagyó órákat
tartani. Szóval, szóval úgy, úgy úgy azt
éreztük, hogy hogy van ebben egy egy
ebben is egy egy flow, amit amire jó
lenne felülni, és valahogy azt érezni,
hogy hogy vagány, hogy kiszedünk mindent
a diákságból, amit amit amit lehet.
Amúgy van ami megmaradt azóta a gimibe,
mint szokás vagy mint így visszatérő,
ami amit ti alkított? Szerintem nem
biztos, hogy azóta folyamatosan, de
például a kávézót is láttam, hogy most
is al rádióról is hallottam, hogy egy jó
pár évig működött, aztán nem tudom, hogy
most működik-e. Azt hiszem nem. Pont a
podcast kapcsán, mikor voltunk bent,
akkor említettem, hogy mi hoztuk létre a
rádiót, és kérdeztem tőlük, hogy van, és
azt mondták, hogy nincs. Úgyhogy kedves
gimisek, lehet jönni podcastet csinálni.
Most ez a modern rádióműfaj, úgyhogy
úgyhogy igen, ezt lehet
folytatni.
Jó. Arra gondoltam, hogy akkor egy
kicsit beszéljünk egy másik fontos
szerepedről, az anyaságról, ami nagyon
hangsúlyosan visszatért a a ugye, ahogy
utána néztem, hogy máshol is miket
nyilatkoztál. két gyermeknek az
édesanyja vagy. És az egyik cikkben azt
írtad, vagyis azt mondtad, hogy abban a
pillanatban, mi helyt a kezedbe fogtad
Annát és az első pillantását megláttad,
abban a pillanatban, valami teljesen új
érzés, egy új korszak kezdete volt
számodra. a az, aki kívülről nézheti az
élet életét, valakinek a színészet
mintha nem férne össze az anyasággal,
mintogyha az a fajta élet, amit a
színészi világ kínálmin reutív képekről
beszélek, az mintogyha ellentétes lenne
egy egy szülőnek a feladatával,
hogy abban a pillanatban mihely tegyük
fel, Anna megszületett, utána volt két
évszüneted? Hogy élted meg ezt a két
évszünetet? Igen, én mindkét gyerekkel
elmentem két évre a szülési szabadságra,
mert azt gondolom, hogy az, hogy
gyereket hozunk a világra, az nem
annyiban merül ki, hogy megszűjük, és
akkor ott itt ott jó helyen van. Főleg,
hogy a az első két év az rendkívül
fontos a gyerekek
érzelmi biztonságának a felépítésében.
Úgyhogy nem is volt kérdés számomra,
hogy otthon kell nekem maradnom. Az első
gyereknél kicsit zúzósabb volt az egész,
ugyanis akkor még Budapesten laktunk, és
eléggé sokat voltam egyedül vele.
Ugyanis a férjem elég sokat dolgozott,
és így reggeltől estig Annával voltam,
és hirtelen estem ki az egész
körforgásból, fiatal is voltam. És úgy
azt azt Hány éves voltál? 26. 26. És úgy
azt is éreztem akkor, hogy mondta a
férjem, hogy de hát miért nem
beszélgetek a játszótéren az anyukákkal?
És mondtam, hogy én barátságos ember
vagyok, én beszélgetek, de én nem arról
akarok beszélgetni, hogy a gyereknek
hány foga van, hogy hányas pelenkát
hord, vagy éppen ma mondta ki az első
babát, hanem én valahogy az életről
akarok, tehát hogy ebben vagyok. és
valahogy az hiányzott, hogy hogy
felnőtt emberekkel az életről, ahogy
addig is beszéljünk. És Gergőnél már
például azut hazaköltöztünk, és rá két
évre született Gergő, és vele már nem
volt ez probléma, ugyanis itthon mégis
jobb itthoni, barátságosabb közegben
voltam, ahol ahol belefért az, hogy akár
a férjem anyukája, akár az én anyukám
egy félórára elvitte sétálni, és akkor
én beülhettem mondjuk a barátnőmmel egy
kávéra, és ezek néha ilyen életmentők
azért. Abszolút. Vagy vagy
visszaemlékszem arra, hogy például
Pesten az volt egy kikapcsolódás, hogy
mondjuk hazajött a férje mester,
lefektettük Annát és ott volt egy ilyen
éjjel nappali üzlet, nem akarom a nevét
mondani, és akkor oda elmentem én lehet,
hogy éjfél után, és akkor csak így
bambultam ki magamból, és azon vettem
észre magam, tudod, hogy a kosarat így
mozgatom, mintha az is a babakocsi
lenne. Szóval volt ilyen, de ennek
ellenére nem bánom, hogy velük voltam
otthon, és megéltem a szépségét és és
minden árnyoldalát is annak, hogy hogy
nem alszik el a gyerek, és akkor emiatt
ideges vagy, és mire elalszik, arra jön
egy motoros, és felkölti. Tehát igen,
hát emlékszem én is, hogy ugye az az a
mozdulatod, ahogy a ahogy nyugtatgatod
az a bevásárlókocsit, hogy ahányszor
hallottam egy egy babát vagy egy-egy
csecsemőt felsírni, egyből egy ilyen egy
ilyen mozgó, egy ilyen nyugtató mozgás
úgy úgy elindult a testemben anélkül,
hogy tudnám, mert mert annyit próbáltam
az én lányaimat így nyugtatgatni, és és
tényleg ez egy nehéz időszak volt, és
tényleg elég tükörszimmetrikus ilyen
szempontból az életünk, hogy mi
Kolozsváron voltunk abban az időszakban,
az első nehéz időszakban is.
nagyon-nagyon hiányzott egy szülő
jelenléte, hogy az a az a az a napi egy
óra, amikor kicsit kiszabadulunk és a
koktább kiengedjük a a gőzt. Szóval
akkor akkor voltak kihívások Budapesten
ilyen szempontból. Igen. Közben meg
nagyon élveztük azt, hogy mi ilyen
fiatalon ott van velünk Anna, és és
valahogy szerintem végig úgy neveltük
őt, vagy ezt úgy adta a gép, hogy soha
nem kisgyerekként szóltunk hozzá, hanem
mintha ő is, tehát hogy így egy harmadik
felnőtt volt
velünk ott,
és tehát tehát nagyon nagyon jó volt ez
a baráti körben is ő volt az első,
úgyhogy ezt is picit fura volt megélni,
hogy mindenki ment ki még bulizni, és
akkor mi nem tudtunk. Utána meg az volt
a jó, hogy mikor mi már mi tudtunk,
akkor meg minden vagy rossz, akkor már
mindenki másnak lett gyereke. De de
mindezzel együtt nagyon jó jó jó volt ez
így. És és azt megélni. Igen. Amikor
megláttam, akkor egyszerre volt felemelő
ez, hogy megszületett és egészséges és
jó, és egyszerre nagyon folytogató vagy
félelmetes az, hogy hogy most egy életen
keresztül van valaki, akire vigyáznom
kell az addigi saját magamon
kívül, hogy hogy valaki, aki akiért
felelősséggel tartozom, hogy hogy mit
tanul meg, hogy mit lát. És most így
akár a Netflix kamaszok sorozatát
végignézve egyre félelmetesebb, hogy
hogy mi az, amit amit amit te tudsz
adni, és emiatt nem lehet félvárról
venni ezeket a a gyerekneveléses
kérdéseket, és emiatt kell tényleg ott
lenni
mellettük. Mi minden nap kérdés, tehát
minden nap kérdés, hogy mit csinálsz
jól, mit csinálsz rosszul. Én mindig
megpróbálok, nyilván régebb nagyon sokat
olvastam is
pszichológusoktól válaszokat,
anyapszichológiát, hogyan legyünk elég
jó szülők, hogyan legyünk jó szülők, de
de nekem az vált a legjobban be, amit én
érzek, és azt hiszem, hogy nem akarok
nagy dolgokat elérni, annyit akarok
elérni, és talán ez az egyetlen, hogyha
bármi van, akkor tudják, hogy ott
vagyunk, és és jöhetnek oda bármivel.
Ezt Ferd már számomra nagyon jól
megfogalmazta. Azt mondta, hogy neki az
volt a célja örökké a gyermekeivel, hogy
a cinkosa legyen a gyermekeinek, hogy
ahányszor ahányszor valami probléma van,
akkor így össze tudjanak kacsintani és
egymást megtalálni. gyakorlatilag erről
megtalál meg megtartani meg igen. Az
egyik hazugság, amit így egyre inkább
meg tudok fogalmazni így magamban,
nagyon tehát ami amit látok, az hogy az
én baráti körömben is egyszerre lett ez
probléma, hogy amikor megszülettek a
gyerekek, a nők úgy érezték, hogy
bezáródnak a lakásba, és értéktelen,
amit tesznek. amiatt értéktelen, mert
láthatatlan egyrészt. És a másik pedig
az, hogy minden, ami látható és mérhető
kívül van, és fizetést adnak érte, az az
nem anyasághoz köthető és gyerekekhez
köthető. Úgyhogy mi Julival a nehéz úton
így kellett ezt megtanuljuk. Viszont
megfogalmaztam egy nagyon érdekes
dolgot. Kíváncsi vagyok a véleményedre.
Az egyik félelme Julinak az volt, hogy
el fog menni mellette a szakma, hogy
mire nekünk három gyermekünk van, mire
visszatér újra a szakmába mármi ő
építész, akkor akkor a szakma már
annyira elhaladt mellette, hogy nem fog
tudni felszállni úgymond a vonatra, mert
már messze-messze előtte lesz. És
nem csak az történt, hogy fel tudott
szállni, hanem rá kellett jöjjek arra,
hogy ez pont a homlokegyenes ellentéte
történt, mintogyha gyereket vállalt
volna. ugyanis praktikusan most
építészként, hogyha valaki egy családi
házat tervez, kérdés az, hogy kiből lesz
jobb családi házvező? Az akinek van
családja és belülről látja ezeket a
logisztikai problémákat, vagy pedig az,
akinek nem volt, mert tegyük fel, vagy
nagyon-nagyon kitolta a a
gyermekvállalást.
És úgy felmerült bennem az a gondolat,
hogyha én lennék a sátán, én pont ezt
csinálnám. Azt csinálnám, hogy
elhitetném a nőkkel, hogy a
gyermekvállalás az nem jó. Ha ha muszáj
vállalni, akkor minél később
vállaljanak, és max egyet, mert mert le
fognak maradni mindenről. Na most a te
esetedben én nagyon kíváncsi lennék,
hogy te mit tapasztaltál, hogy téged
jobb vagy rosszabb színésznővé, tehát
lemaradtál-e valamiről a pályát, tehát
azáltal, hogy nem gyakoroltál azatt a
két év alatt úgy, mintogyha dolgoztál
volna, vagy pedig, hogy pont mire
visszatértél, egy olyan dimenzióját
hoztad az életednek, ami azelőtt nem
volt ott, és nem is lehetett volna ott,
hogyha ha te folyamatosan dolgozol?
Szerintem ez bennem nem kérdés, tehát
hogy mindenképp azt gondolom, hogy
mindenki jobb lesz attól. Akár itt
eszembe jut például Nagy Ervinnel néztem
annó egy interjút, és ő mondta el azt,
hogy soha nem tudott addig például sírni
színpadon, amíg nem született meg a
lánya, és utána ez így sikerült. Én most
ennyire konkrét példát nem tudok
felhozni. Viszont azt gondolom, hogy az,
hogy valaki anya lesz, valaki apa lesz,
egy új minőséget hoz az életébe, egy
mélyebb megélést, egy egy olyan plusz
kapaszkodót, ami ami minden egyes
mozdulatában utána benne lesz. És és
ezek a ezek az elmélyültebb dolgok
persze, hogy hozzátesznek egy emberhez,
és ha hozzátesznek egy emberhez, akkor
hozzátesznek a színészhez is, és ezáltal
hozzátesznek ahhoz, ahogy ő egy
karaktert meg tud jeleníteni a
színpadon. Én azt hiszem, hogy mélyítik
az embert az ilyenfajta megélések. Igen.
Igen. Meg meg ez a az, amit mondtál
Erwinnel kapcsolatban, hogy addig nem
tudott sírni, ameddig nem
volt nem született meg a saját kislánya.
Ez ez tényleg az amiatt fontos,
legalábbis így, ahogy magamnak
megfogalmaztam. Most nemrég beszélgettem
a drognaplónak a
a tehát ez egy monodráma, nem tudom,
hogy
láttad-e. Ez egy egy drogos embernek az
életéről szól. És jaj, a
gyergyóiak. Igen. Igen. És az egyik
dolog, ami feltűnt nekem, különösen
feltűnt, az az, hogy mennyire fizikailag
megviselte ez a a az 1:1 perc. Tehát a
végére leizzadt, és látszott, hogy hogy
teljesen kifáradt. És ez a fajta emberi
reakció, amelyik a verbális szint alatt
van, tehát miközben nézem a másikat,
hogy fizikailag küzd ezzel a szereppel,
ez bennem is elindít egy olyan
valószínűleg hormonokat indít el, átélem
én is az ő szenvedését. És ez ez
pontosan az a különbség, ami ami egy
olyan tanár között, aki csak úgy mutogat
a táblán, és elmondja, hogy ez így kell,
és ezt úgy kell, vagy versus az, aki aki
átéli és átadja. Tehát, hogy hogy és
ezért fontos a művészet, hogy az
empátiádat növeli. Ezért fontos igen.
Például és a gyermeknek a születése az
tényleg, ahogy megfogalmaztad, hogy
ezért a személyért mostantól kezdve
felelősséggel fogsz tartozni, allén
benne, vagy nincs visszaút? Tehát már
nem lehet ezt visszacsinálni, nem lehet,
nem lehet visszaküldeni, mint az emagon.
Ez ez egy olyan, hogy allén és és a
világ veszélyes, és egyre
veszélyesebbnek tűnik ez az érzetünk
belülről. És hogy akkor ha már benne
vagyunk, akkor akkor ezt hogyan fogjuk
csinálni? Hogyan válok én a lehető
legjobb énemmé? Hogy a lehető legjobb
anya legyek és a lehető legjobb személy
azért, hogy hogy mindent átadjak, amit
szükséges ahhoz mint tudás és
mint hogyan válik belőle egy olyan
felnőtt, aki megállja a helyét ebben a
világban. És ez a ez ez karakterformálú
abszolút. Szerintem a legfontosabb az,
hogy önazonosak legyünk. Tehát, hogy én
van olyan, hogy nem tudom, valami miatt
felhúztam magam, lehet, és legtöbbször
ilyen van, hogy már van bennem egy
feszültség, mondjuk valamit olyat
csinálnak, és akkor így rájuk zódítom,
és akkor utána ez lecseng, és van olyan,
hogy odamegyek, és azt mondom, hogy ne
haragudyál.
Amit mondtam, abban valószínűleg mindig
tartom, vagy hogy ebben igazam volt, de
hogy hogy valami feszültség miatt ez
rajtad jött ki. Tehát hogy hogy akár
azt, hogy hogy lássanak bocsánatot
kérni, hogy lássák azt, hogy hogy te is
hibázhatsz, és hogy hogy az nem világ
vége. Lássák azt, hogy hogy újra lehet
gondolni a dolgokat. Tehát
mindenféle hibáimmal együtt lássanak.
Ühüm. Nem, nem kell azt gondolják, hogy
én a nem tudom ki vagyok, hogy egy
félisten vagy, aki aki érinthetetlen és
tökéletes. Igen.
Mert akkor ők ők se fognak arra
törekedni. Tehát szerintem az egyik
legnagyobb hiba, amit elkövethetünk,
hogyha egy ilyen nagyon nagy megfelelési
kényszert rakunk a gyerekeinkre. Igen.
Mert abból jön aztán egy csomó
szorongás,
depresszió,
kiszolgáltatottság. Nem tudok
megfelelni, nem tudok beilleszkedni a
társadalomba.
kívülálló maradok, és akkor jönnek a az
öngyilkossági kísérletek, meg satöbbi,
meg
satöbbi. Ez hogyan oldod meg amúgy két
gyermekkel ezt a ezt a logisztikát?
Hogyan? Tehát, hogy hogy néha turnézni
kell, gondolom, néha
estébe hajló programjaid vannak, hogy
ezt hogyan tudod megoldani?
esténként apa szokott akkor otthon
lenni, és amikor én próbálok, vagy
előadásom van, akkor ő olvas mesét, ő
végzi el ezeket a teendőket. De amúgy
sokszor olyankor is, amikor otthon
vagyok, én megyek a kicsihez, ő megy
Annához. Tehát, hogy ez soha nem volt
kérdés nálunk, hogy ezek így megosztva
történnek ezek a dolgok. Ha meg turné
van, akkor nagyon sokat segítenek a
nagyszülők, az én szüleim is, az ő
szülei is itt élnek, úgyhogy várják őket
az iskolában, hazaviszik, és ameddig apa
dolgozik, addig ott vannak velük.
Mekkora áldás a nagyszülő. Így van. És
és nagyon jó, mert egyébként nem volt ez
teljesen evidens, hogy mi hazaköltözünk,
hanem gondol gondolkodtunk azon, hogy
maradjunk. Elkezdtünk nézni. Nyilván
akkor már Anna két éves volt, én vissza
kellett volna menjek dolgozni, kellett
volna valaki, aki akár a bölcsödéből
elveszi, mert én még nem vé végeztem, és
és nem tudtam. Tehát néztük ezeket az
embereket,
a bébi felügyelőket, hogy mondják ezt,
bébittereket, és nem tudtam volna
nyugodt szívvel rájuk bízni senkinek.
Sosem volt akkor ilyen babyszitteretek.
Nem, nem.
maximum ismerős. Tehát, hogy olyan, hogy
egy idegenre azt éreztem, hogy nem
tudnék nyugodt lenni, hogy én
csinálhatnék bármit, de ha attól félek,
hogy most épp mit csinál a gyerekem, az
az úgy nem lenne jó. Úgyhogy egy egy
nagy áldás, hogy itt vannak a
nagyszülők. Anna Anna 11, Gergő 6. Akkor
láttak ők is már téged a színpadon,
gondolom többször is. Igen. Igen.
Gyerekelőadásban. Gyerekelőadásban.
Milyen volt nekik így látni téged, hogy
egy teljesen más szerepben élvezik?
Ezt természetes. Akkor gondolom nekik,
hogy most itt van anya, aki aki főz, és
aki akivel együtt csinálunk ilyen-olyan
dolgokat, és ott van anya, aki ugyancsak
anya, csak éppen most egy más szerepben
van. Így van. Igen. És Anna például bele
is kóstolgatott néha akár egy-egy
reklámfilmbe.
Ő volt egy szereplő, de de mondjuk,
hogyha hívnak a rádióhoz reklámot
mondani, vagy bármilyen szöveget, akkor
gyakran jönnek ők is, mert vannak néha
gyerekkarakterek is. És például Gergő
folyamatosan Annával mentünk, és ő akkor
így ki is kérte magának, hogy ő is
szeretne felmondani reklámszöveget.
Úgyhogy úgy vagyok vele, hogy soha nem
erőltettem semmit. se azt, hogy
versmondó versenyekre menjenek, amikor
nekik kedvük van, és ők jönnek ezzel,
akkor akkor persze szívesen segítek. Meg
látom, hogy élvezik, de ugyanúgy Gergő
nagyon élvezi a matek képleteket is,
vagy az összeadást, kivonást, úgyhogy
érdekes ez is, hogy meglátni a
gyerekeidben a másikat, vagy saját
magadat. Igen, ilyen szempontból nagyon
érdekesen egészítitek ki a pároddal
egymást, mert ő egy egy közgazdasági
szakember, és nem is tudom, hogy le
lehetne-e homlokegyenest ilyen
sztereotip szempontból mondom egy másik
típusú karaktert
keresni. Amúgy mivel ismerem
személyesen, azért tudom, hogy nem
homlok egyenes. Tehát neki is van
hajlama arra, hogy közönség előtt
beszéljen. Nagyon szépen beszél és és
neki is van rutinja ebbe, hogy hogy
szervezzen. Tehát látszik, hogy hogy van
közös az életetekben. De tényleg ez
okozott nehézséget így a
kapcsolatotokban. Az, hogy ő egy egy
strukturált racionális valaki, aki aki
inkább a számok terén jártasabb. Te
pedig gyanítom, hogy ilyen szempontból
nem annyira, de lehet, hogy ez is
javítics, ki ne haragudj, hogy nem
igazad van ebben. Tehát én nem vagyok
oda annyira. Bár ha ezt most Dávid Géza
tanár úr látja, akkor biztos mosolyog
rajtam. Ugyanis ő nagyon szerette volna,
hogy én nyolcadiktól menjek Matekinóra.
van valamilyen szintű képességem,
affinitásom rá, de de én pontosan
tudtam, hogy hogy engem a színház
érdekel, és úgy voltam vele, hogy akkor
meg azt az időt, amit kellene a
színusszal meg a kszínusszal eltöltenem,
azt inkább eltölteném az olvasással, a
versek
megtanulásával, és és emiatt aztán nem
is mentem arra.
De hogy visszatérve szerintem nagyon jó
ez, vagyis nagyon jó dinamikával tudunk
mi működni most már 19 éve, úgyhogy az
életemnek már több részében voltam,
voltunk együtt, mint mint külön. nagyon
ismer is. Azt hiszem, hogy ő ismer a
legjobban, és és nagyon nagyon tudja az
én érzékeny pontjaimat, és tudja azt is,
hogy mikor kell egy-egy jó poénnal, vagy
egy-egy kisebb beszólással
helyre tenni. És ezenkívül nagyon segít
például engem a az a mindenféle
pirospontprukciós, akár egyesületes,
akár vállalkozásos dolgaimban. ugyanis
mindig az van, hogy én kitalálom, én
kreatív vagyok, én semmi nem állíthat
meg, tehát hogy így szárnyalnék, de az,
hogy egy szerződést én elolvassak, vagy
egy az ANAFnál leadjak egy de cheesziét,
vagy deklaráciét, hát ez annyira
meghalad engem, hogy ha egyet is
kellene, akkor valószínűleg már rég
lenne Pirospont produkció, és akkor ő
ezt mindig nekem megcsinálja.
kicsit kalandozzunk akkor a piros pont
produkció fele. Mesélnél erről a
kezdeményezésedről? Mi is ez a
Pirospont? És
milyen eseményeket szerveztetek eddig?
Igen, a Pirospont produkció 2015-ben
jött létre, pont annak kapcsán is, hogy
meséltem neked, hogy talán ez a
szervezés volt a az egyik út, ahol azt
éreztem még, hogy esetleg elindulhatnék.
És olyan szerencsém volt, hogy a a három
év után, amikor az alapképzést végeztem
az egyetemen és felvételiztem vissza
mesteri szakra is,
színészakon, egyszer csak kiírtak egy
ilyen szakot, hogy kulturális marketing,
menedzsment, impresszárió,
rendezvényszervezés, és azt mondtam,
hogy ez így mintha nekem lett volna
kitalálva. És ilyen mellékszakként
beiratkoztam arra is. És a környéken a a
kulturális intézményeknek a vezetőivel
járhattam két évet, ami nagyon jó volt.
Az is nagyon jó volt, hogy voltak itt
olyan emberek, akik teljesen a másik
oldalról jöttek, tehát csak a szervezés,
és ők nem láttak bele a abba abba az
alkotói munkába, ahol én megfordultam.
Ezért voltak például olyan
beszélgetéseink, ahol ahol ezen ment a
veszekedés, hogy jó, de akkor ez fontos
egy színésznek. Ők megmondták, hogy jó,
de a költségvetést nem lehet így vagy
úgy módosítani.
Úgyhogy elvégeztem ezt a szakot, és
akkor amikor kiköltöztünk Budapestre,
akkor pont ez volt a tervem, hogy hogy
én ebben szeretnék tapasztalatot
szerezni.
És tényleg a budapesti operet színházban
dolgozhattam szinte két évet Anna
születéséig, ahol nagyon vagány dolgok
születtek és nagyon
érdekes
különböző produkcióknak a hátterébe
láthattam bele. Nagyon jó volt. Közben
meg azt éreztem, hogy lenne egy csomó
minden, amit úgy érzem, hogy haza
kellene hozni. És ez az igény hozta
létre akkor a Pirospont
produkciót. A névválasztás az főként a a
Sándorműve, ugyanis mint ettük, vettük,
hogy mi legyen, ne is legyen nagyon
művészi. És mivel volt nekem ez a
szenvedélyem, ilyen piros,
pöttyös, vintage cuccok, meg a konyhám
így nézett ki, ezért egyszer csak így
ezt mondta, hogy piros pont, és nagyon a
végén voltunk, hogy kellett menni
beiratni ezt a ezt az entitást, és és
akkor ez így rajt rajtunk maradt. rajtam
maradt, és
és akkor 15-ben elkezdtem
pszichológusokat
hívni erdélyi városokba. Akkor főként a
az anyaság témaköre érdekelt, de aztán
ezt érzelmi intelligenciára, Kádár Anna
Máriára, Tari Anna Mária, Deliága Éva,
Vida Ágnes, ők először nálam nálam
voltak meghívott vendégként, és akkor
egy idő után elkezdett foglalkoztatni
az, hogy a művészet becsempészni a
hétköznapokba. Tehát ezek ilyen
beszélgetések voltak az anyaságról.
Igen, tehát, hogy egy ilyen előadó
kerekasztaléskén
lehetett kérdezni is, de egyébként
előadás. Tehát jött a a pszichológus,
felállt a színpadra, megvásárolták az
emberek a jegyet és végighallgatták az
előadását az adott témakörben is a végén
kérdezhettek. Szóval ezt ezt annó még
így én én indítottam el így több
városban, aztán Jaj, ráadásul több
városban is. Igen, igen. Tehát a az első
az Udvarhely. Csíkszered, a
Marosvásárhely, Sebsi Szentzentgyörgy.
Aztán ez ment végig, és volt olyan is,
hogy Kolozsvár, Nagyvárad és Zatmár.
És akkor közben megérkezett Gergő,
közben visszamentem a színházba, így
egyre kevesebb energiám jutott ezekre a
fajta
dolgokra,
de meg közben bejöttek nyilván látva
ezt, hogy ez így működik, bejöttek más
cégek is, akik néhol akár
etikátlanul léptek fel, és nyúltak le
úgy embereket, hogy hogy köpni, nyelni
nem tudtam. vagy egy kicsit mesélj, nem
tudom, hogy miről van szó pontosan. Hát
volt egy ilyen ilyen pillanat az
életemben, amikor felhívott valaki,
bemutatkozott és kikérdezett egy adott
pszichológussal kapcsolatban, hogy
látta, hogy én hoztam őt több erdélyi
városba, és hogy hogy ezek hogy voltak.
És mivel ő hivatkozott egy olyan
emberre, aki nekem fontos,
és segített nekem, én is segítettem
neki, és és tényleg azt éreztem, hogy
akkor segíteni kell, hogyha ő
ráatkozik. Ezért én, mint
egy nyitott könyv, így mindent
elmondtam. Nem voltak ezek olyan nagy
titkok, csak hogy nyilván nem azt tette,
hogy szia, XY vagyok ennek a cégnek az
embere, és szeretném elhozni ezt az
embert, ezért kérdezem, hogy te hogy
csináltad? hanem hanem ilyen
háttérstatégiával, és én így egy az
egybe minden olyan dolgot kiadtam, amit
én addig felépítettem akár egyedül itt.
És akkor utána láttam, hogy jaj, akkor
jön-e jön ez az ember hozzá. És akkor
azt éreztem, hogy na látod, és itt itt
jön be az, hogy én miért nem gondolkozom
sztereotipikusan akár emberekkel
kapcsolatban, mert én úgy gondolkodom,
hogy hogy emberek vagyunk, és hogy csak
ne csináljuk ezt. Tehát, hogy ez egy
ilyen nem túl etikus versenybés volt,
vagy nem, nem is tudom, hogy ezt ezt
minek nevezzem. Tehát ez az a pont, amit
én biztos, hogy nem csinálnék meg.
Abszolút. Soha nem hívnám fel sem.
É se tudtam, hogy ez ez működik. És
akkor na az ilyen helyzetekre sokkal
praktikusabb. Például Sándor, aki mondja
nekem, hogy de Orsi, tisztában kell
lenni ezeknek a nevek, ezeknek a
különböző cégeknek a vezetőivel, és
egyből a a nevet így így kellett volna
tudjad, és bezársz. De mondjuk én ugyan
olyan vagyok, hogy úgy sem zártam volna
be. Tehát igen, csak hogy mindig azt
gondolnám, hogy ezek így nem nem
fordulhatnak elő. Tehát hogy bármilyen
élethelyzetben legyünk egymással
emberiek.
Igen. A amúgy a hazaköltözés ügy az
jutott eszembe, hogy megkérdezzem,
hogy másik pont ilyen kép, amikor mi
hazaköltöztünk Kolozsváról, az első
félelmem az volt, hogy itt Székel
Udvarhelyen nem lehet megélni, mint
informatikus. Sokkal könnyebb egy
kolozsvári közegben megélni, mint itt,
ami nem igaz, hogy ugyanez a félelem
bennetek is ott volt, hogy most így
színészként meg közgazdászként azért
mégis csak egy nagy városba könnyebb
megélni, mint Székely Udvarhelyen. Volt
bennetek egy ilyen félelem, hogyha
hazaköltöztek, mi lesz?
bennem annyira nem volt, mert én itt
nőttem fel
a a színházban, csak nem a színpadi
részen, hanem a nézőtéri részen. Tehát,
hogy én már gyerekkorom óta folyamatosan
bérlettel jártam, és csodáltam a a
Finciski Andreát és Dunkler Róbertet,
akik már akkor itt voltak, és néztem
azt, hogy de jó lenne egyszer nekem is
ide felállni erre a színpadra. Tehát
bennem volt egy ilyen fajta vágy.
Úgyhogy én, amikor már az egyetemet
elvégeztem, és hívtak a színházhoz, már
akkor jöttem volna, csak akkor meg
Sándort felvették kint Budapesten
mesterizni, és akkor meg úgy voltam,
hogy annyira régóta távkapcsolatban
vagyunk, hogy akkor inkább megyek vele.
Úgyhogy amikor költöztünk haza, számomra
nem volt kérdés, hogy én ennek örülök,
és én szeretnék itthon színész lenni.
neki volt, és neki szerintem most is
nehezebb, mert ő az a szak, amit ő
elvégzett, egy ilyen gazdasági elemző
szak, abban valójában ilyen nagy
városokban tudna
igazán otthon lenni és megmutatni azt,
hogy mit tud ő.
Úgyhogy, úgyhogy ez, ez egy kérdés volt
akkor is, meg mostanában is kérdés, hogy
de de úgy jöttünk azzal, hogy bármikor
visszamegyünk, úgyhogy ezt nem zártuk le
ezt a dolgot. Ühüm. Én azt gondolom,
hogy vagyunk egymással
annyira tehát tartunk is egymáshoz
annyira, hogyha ő mondjuk egy év múlva
vagy bármikor azt mondja, hogy most neki
van egy egy jó lehetőség.
Bár igaz, hogy én azt mondtam, hogy én
nem mennék más nyelvterületre,
mert én azt gondolom, hogy színész az
ember az anyanyelvén lehet a
legjobban. És és emiatt, mikor kérdés
volt, hogy mondjuk Ausztriába költözni
vagy német
nyelvterületre, persze nem attól féltem,
hogy nem lehet a nyelvet elsajátítani
egy-két év alatt, de úgy elsajátítani,
hogy hogy anyanyelvi szinten egy
színházban játszak. Nem gondolom, hogy
ez
megoldható. Sokan csinálják, de a
legtöbben úgy csinálják, mondjuk, hogy
angol filmekben
játszanak a a magyar
akcentusukkal bármilyen bevándorlót. Így
van. Így van. Igen, igen, igen. Amúgy el
tudod képzelni, hogy filmben is
szerepel, tehát filmszínész nő is
legyél. Igen, igen. Nagyon, nagyon
izgat.
Például amikor reklámokat forgattunk,
akkor vagy volt például Budapesten egy
egy film, egy rövid film, amit a Nagy
Pál Orsival egyébként a a Nyitva című
nagyjátékfilmnek a rendezőjével, vagy
akár most a Hunyadi sorozatnak is a a
rendezőjével, a vár résznek a
rendezőjével, mert ott többen rendezték,
forgattam és Orsival nagyon szerettem
dolgozni, és azt gondolom, hogy hogy
azért lenne fontos, hogy minél többet
forgassunk, vagy emiatt szeretek nagyon
stúdió előadásokat is játszani. Ugyanis
a stúdió előadásokban szerintem azt a
fajta színészi attitűdöt kell felvenni,
ami a filmben is fontos, tehát hogy
kicsiben, rezgésekből, csak annyiból
mondjuk, hogy a a szemed, a tekinteted,
vagy a vagy egy egy ránc megmozdul az
arcodon, ezzel lehet
a legszebben festeni embereket,
karaktereket. Nem úgy, mint mondjuk egy
nagy színpadon, ahol nagyobb gesztust
kell. Igen. Mert távolabb ülnek az
emberek, nem látják az ilyen előt. Igen.
Igen. És és én azt is érzem, hogy hozzám
közelebb állnak a stúdió előadások.
Tehát én én azt gondolom, hogy én ilyen
minimálba tudok úgy
igazán önmagam lenni, vagy a
visszafogottabb, visszafogottabban
megszülettetni, megszülni egy-egy
karaktert. Egy kicsit beszélgessünk a
podcastedről is, ami nemrég indult,
pontosabban egy fél éve talán, ami
lehet, hogy egy kicsit több már. Több.
Igen. Igen. A tavaly nyáron forgattuk az
elsőt. Tavaly nyáron. egy kicsit
mesélnél erről a saját podcastedről, és
hogy mi is a hány meghívottad volt, mi a
célja ennek a podcastnek. Igen, és
közben vissza is térek még csak ennyire,
de amúgy ez pont ide csatlakozik a piros
pont kapcsán, hogy akkor a
pszichológusok után meg elkezdtem a
művészettel foglalkozni úgy, hogy picit
másképp, mint ahogy ahogy az emberek
megszokták, picit újszerűen,
izgalmasabban, több szempontból
megközelítően, és így jött létre az
értékelünk, ami egy ilyen összművészeti
előadás, és máris odakanyarodtam a
podcasthez, ugyanis magát a a verselő
podcastnek az ötletét az értékelünk
adta, hogy megismerkedtem a környékünkön
élő művészekkel, legyenek
képzőművészek, irodalmárok, és azt
éreztem, hogy vá mennyi sok vagányember
van itt, és mégsem hallunk felőlük. És
valahogy ennek a ennek a hallatásnak
akartam lenni adni akartam adni én egy
mikrofont, hogy ne legyen az, hogy hogy
felnőnek generációk úgy, hogy mondjuk
nem hallották Farkasma névát beszélni,
nem
hallották nem tudom nagymos Ildikót
beszélni és nyilván erre vannak vannak
próbálkozások a rendhagyóirodalmi
órákkal, ahol tancik behívják őket
néhol.
De én azt gondolom, hogy minél nagyobb
teret adunk ennek, minél minél jobban
világgákürtöljük azt, hogy itt a
kicsi 35000-es
városunkból mennyi sok művész ment ki a
világba, milyen sok nagyembernek adtunk
mi alapot, adtunk iskolát, annál annál
büszkébbek lehetünk egyrészt magunkra,
meg annál többen lesznek kíváncsiak
arra, hogy mi is van itt Székely
Udvarhelyen. Tehát ha én visszagondolok,
hogy milyen nagy dolog volt látni
Kányádi Sándorról egy-egy képet, vagy
ahogy minden osztálynak a falára ki
voltak téve régebb, ez a napsugár
kinyomtatta a költőket, úgy gondolom,
hogy nekünk is kötelességünk ezt a
kortársirodalommal véghez vinni.
Igen, mert ki más, ha nem mi, ki más
tanítja meg, ki más mutatja meg a
gyerekeinknek a költészetet, ha nem mi.
Egyébként 10 éves koráig minden gyerek
ír
verseket, és 10 éves kora után egyszer
csak ez így így elakad. Pedig ez egy
tanulható készség. Gergő is ír, meg Anna
is ír.
Nem tudom, Annát még nem kérdeztem.
Gergő szokott költögetni, ő nagyon
szeretett. ilyen vicces rímeket faragni
például nagyon élvezni. Mondjuk ez
tényleg így van. A gyerekeim is tehát
ilyen rímeket faragnak azért nem
nevezném verseknek, de de lehet, hogy én
nem definiálom jól mi mi egy vers.
Pontosan nem ezért pont ezért a vers ez
egy ilyen ősi dolog, ami ami ami velünk
születik. Tehát hogyha belegondolunk
abba, hogy hogyan tanulunk meg beszélni,
legtöbbször ilyen kis
rigmusokat mondunk a gyereknek, és ő is
így fog válaszolni. Tehát például most
amit mondtam, hogy Gergő, Gergő mindig
az ilyen vicces, tehát hogy mondom, hogy
kisfiam, és akkor visszaválaszol
ugyanolyan szótagszámba. Nagy anyám.
Tehát, hogy így mindig így szereti
például az ellentétet is, vagy kis
apukám, vagy vagy nagyon játékos, és
hogy ezt elfelejtjük. Azért felejtjük
el, mert nem tudjuk ezt ezt jól a helyén
kezelni. nem tudjuk úgy a helyén
kezelni, hogy ez nekik érdekes legyen.
És és ebben nagyon fontos a
kortársköltészet, a
kortársirodalom, mert nem Balasi Bálint,
mondjuk ő még, de hogy nem Jánusz
Pannúniusz versein keresztül kell
megfogni a gyermekeket, hanem például
egy varródani verssel. És akkor
elmondasz neki egy varródani verset, és
azt mondja, hogy vá, a költészet ilyen
is lehet, és akkor így megy tovább, mert
felkeltetted az érdeklődését. Megy
tovább, olvass mást, és el fog jutni
valószínűleg Jánusz Pannóniuszig is. De
az út, ahonnan elindultál, nem mindegy.
És a kortárs nyelvezet az, amit a
legjobban értünk. A kortársköltő, ha
megjelenik, és legyen ő egy egy bördsek
is, egy valami, akkor érzi azt az a
gyerek, hogy ő ezzel tud
azonosulni. Akkor érzi azt,
hogy hogy érdekli ez a téma, hogyha az a
téma valóban az, amire ő hétköznap
rezonál, amivel ő találkozik.
Tudod, a erről mindenképpen akarok
beszélni, mert az az igazság, hogy
bennem is változtattál valamit. tudat
tehát annik hogy tudtád tudtad volna.
Volt egy ilyen emlékem, amikor
készültünk tavaly ilyenkor elutazni a
csapattal egy ilyen csapatépítőre, és az
udvaron gyülekezett a a gyülekeztek a
munkatársaim, és egyszer bejöttél
valakivel, mert éppen a valami versnap
volt, vagy mi mi emlékszel? Április 11 a
magyar, vagyis igen, a magyar költészet
napja egyébként József Attillának a
születésnapján. ünnepeljük ezt és
zseniális volt. Bejöttél a magyar
költészet napján, és a magyar költészet
napjának a a az űrügyén felolvastál
verset. Kérdezted, hogy hogy akkor mivel
legyen kapcsolatos? Láttad, hogy
programozók vagyunk, gyorsan kerestél
egy verset és elszavaltad. Persze jót
szórakoztunk, nagyon jó
volt. És utána pedig valahol mondtad,
hogy a költészet, te meg vagy a
győződve, a költészet és az irodalom az
mindenkinek szól, nem egy szűk elit
elitnek szól. És ezt azt hiszem, hogy
mélyebben megértettem akkor, mert azokat
a versikékekiket mondogattuk magunkban,
meg kacagtunk rajta, meg egy picit össze
is kötött minket. És és erről akarlak
egy kicsit most kérdezni, hogy
én nem feltétlenül ezt tanultam én a
középiskolában, hogy a költészet
mindenkinek szól. Nagyon nehéz verseket
vettünk. És mondta is a magyar tanárnőm,
amúgy szerintem sose gondolná a magyar
tanárnőm, hogy én most versekről fogok
beszélgetni, de mondta is a magyar
tanárnőm, hogy azokat a dolgokat, amiket
most tanulunk, ezeket csak felnőtt
korunkban fogjuk
érteni. Viszont az is lett az eredménye,
hogy nem érdekeltek ezek a dolgok, meg
messze meghaladták a szintemet, és és
akkor azok nekem csak feladatok voltak,
amiket meg kellett oldjak. József
Attillát az, hogy hogy úgy olvassam el
József Attilának az egyik versét, hogy
könnyis legyen a szememben. Ez most
felnőtt életem során az utolsó egy-két
év, amikor am sok minden van mögöttem,
és egy csomó filozófiát megtanultam
időközben, és kezdem érteni egy részét
József Attillának, de hát mégis csak 30
valamennyi évesen kezdtem el megérteni,
hogy hogy egyes sor vajon mire
vonatkozhat.
Szóval ilyen szempontból hogyan hogyan
látod, hogy hogy szólhat mindenkinek egy
vers? Tehát József Attila egy egy nehéz
súlyú
bajnok. Tud József Attilát olvasni a
hétköznapi ember? Igen, tud. A versek a
legmélyebben hangulatokról
szólnak, érzésekről szólnak,
benyomásokról szólnak, arról szólnak,
hogy mi hogy tudunk kapcsolódni, milyen
emléket ébresztenek fel bennünk.
És nem feltétlenül a prózával
ellentétben, ahol mindig van egy
narratíva. Valahonnan indulunk, valahová
eljutunk. A versek néha csak egy-egy
hangulatnak a
megragadása. És azzal találkozni, hogy
elolvasol egy
verset, és visszagörgetsz magadban, és
arra gondolsz, hogy én hol találkoztam
ezzel? Mikor volt az, hogy én ezt
éreztem magamban? Mikor éreztem magam
rezignáltnak? Mikor éreztem azt,
hogy hogy nekem itt most cselekedni
kell, mert föltámadott a tenger. Csak
mondtam egy példát. És és ezek olyan
dolgok, amik már segítettek abban, hogy
te azt a azt a
gondolatmenet tovább vittd, más
perspektívából tekintsél rá, és elkezd
feldolgozni. Tehát azt mondod, amikor
egy verset olvassunk, akkor úgy
olvassuk, hogy ne próbáljuk egyből
megérteni intellektuálisan, hanem
hagyjuk, hogy azt az érzést, amit
felkelt bennünk ez a vers, kezdjük el
magunkba kutatni, hogy mikor éreztünk
hasonlót. Például ez az egyik módszer
is. Érzésszinten kapcsolódni a vers
intellektuális szinten. Igen. egyébként
amerikai kutatásból kimutatták, hogy
amikor verseket olvasunk ilyen
emeriy
felvételekkel, nagyon hasonló három
terület van, amikor az agyunk nagyjából
ugyanúgy reagál. Na mit gondolsz, mik
ezek? Na
lássuk még egyszer. Három hasonló
terület van.
az agyunk hasonlóképpen reagál, mint a
versek olvasás, mint a versek
olvasásakor. Hát szerintem a mesék
például nem. Az egyik az
imádság, a másik a versolvasás és a
harmadik az ilyen nagyon bonyolult
matematikai képletek
megoldása. És ezt soha nem gondoltam
volna. És és ez nekem nekem főként a az
imádság volt egy érdekes dolog, hogy
amikor imádkozol is, akkor szerintem
valahogy ráhagyatkozol az
egészre. Tehát nem gondolkodsz, hanem
mondod és és közben azt gondolod, hogy
ez így így megtörténik az, hogy te
belekerülsz egy ilyen egy egy olyan
állapotba. És a versnek is az, hogy hogy
téged hirtelen beleesz egy hangulatba. a
metaforáknak, a különböző költői
képeknek
köszönhetően elhelyez téged
egy
hangulatgömben. Ezzel már elindít egy
folyamatot,
ami ami tovább fog téged lendíteni ezen.
Így gondolkozom azon, hogy mi a közös
ebbe a háromba, és valahogy most van egy
gondolatom félkész, úgyhogy most együtt
fogjuk ezt megvizsgálni, hogy talán a
háromban az a közös, hogy olyan dolgok
találkoznak mind a három esetben, amik
különállónak tűntek, de mégis mintogyha
egy tökéletes fogaskerékrendszer
egyszerre a helyére kattan, és minden
tökéletesen működik. el tudom képzelni,
hogy hogy
én is inkább egy reál beállítottságú
személy vagyok, hogy az, amikor egy
megoldást látok, amikor látom a
harmóniáját a különböző rendszereknek,
vagy az imaközben, amikor egy újabb
szinten áll össze a világ egységgé,
lehet, hogy ugyanezt tapasztalod vers
alatt is, hogy az, amit előtte nem
gondoltál egynek, az az mégis csak
összetalál és egy.
Igen. Vagy azt azt megélni például, hogy
hogy akár most a verselő szerelem a
Valentinn napi, Bálint napi kiállításunk
kapcsán is 100 szerelmes verset
állítottunk ki. És hogy mennyiféle a
szerelem. Van olyan ember, aki nem
találkozott a szerelemmel? Nincs. De
hogy az a szerelem, ha ha végigolvasták
az emberek, vagy csak ötöt olvastak el,
az öt versen, a szerelemnek öt
különböző nézőpontja mutatkozott meg, és
mindenik igaz volt. És e valahol ebben
tudnak szerintem a versek nagyon sokat
segíteni, hogyha te elveszett vagy egy
problémával, hogyha te nem találod a
kulcsot, nem biztos, hogy annyira ezen
töröd magad, de valahol a kisagyadban ez
kérdésként felmerült benned, és akkor
nem biztos, hogy pont akkor találsz rá
egy versre. Lehet, hogy rég hallottál
róla, de elraktáló elraktározódott a te
saját belső könyvtáradban, és egyszer
csak ki tudod húzni a polcról ezt, és
azt mondani, hú, nem találkoztam vele,
de ebben a versben valaki
érintette, és milyen lenne, ha ezt ezt
megvizsgálnám, hogy ő honnan és máris
közelebb jutottál a
problémához
egyébként. Napi hét hét perc
vershallgatás akár 30 nap alatt is.
Kimutatták ezt is ilyen felmérésekkel,
hogy nagy mértékben csökkenti a
szorongást és az alvás minőségét nagyban
javítja. Ezt ki fogom próbálni. Úgyhogy
tényleg rengeteg olyan olyan funkciója
van, ami és és azt is megmutatták, hogy
a zenehallgatáshoz van a legközelebb a
költészet. Valószínűleg pont a versek
zeneisége miatt sokkal jobban. Tehát
akkor abba a három területbe
berakhatnánk a zenét is.
Igen. Meg valójában a zene is egy olyan,
hogy hogy több szinten harmonizál, több
eltérő hangszer és egy egészet alkot.
Igen. És és megad egy ilyen egy ilyen
tehát a zenét azért is tartják annak,
mert egy ilyen meditációs, egy ilyen
relaxációs állapotba juttatja el az
embereket. És a prózával szemben a
költészet az például a líra, ami
ugyanígy eljuttat egy ilyen állapotba
minket. És most említetted, hogy
ugyanúgy, tehát hogy igen, ugyanaz a az
a gondolatmenet, viszont képzeld, hogy a
költészet még egy picivel tovább megy,
ugyanis ezt is egy ilyen külön vizsgálat
volt. Megfigyelték azt,
hogy a költészet által versolvasás,
vershallgatás kapcsán, főként olvasással
több költőnek a művét hallgatták végig
ilyen nagy költőknek. Shakespeare,
Gőter, Rilke, Schiller satöbbi, és
kimutatták azt a figyelték az embereknek
az arcjátékát, a pulzuszámát és valami
ilyen bőrreakciókat, mint libabőr meg
ilyesmi gépekkel. És ezen kívül adtak
nekik egy gombot, hogy amikor olvassák a
verset, és azt érzik, hogy egy ilyen
izgalmi állapotba jutnak, hogy
jelezhetik, gombot lenyomhatják. Igen.
És akkor mutatták ki, hogy egyébként
ugyanígy, mint a zene, ugyan ugyanúgy
libabőrösek lettek az emberek. A
40%-uk nem 40%-uknál jelent meg maga a
libabőr, de a többieknél is szor vagy
egy ilyen jófajta chills, ezt úgy
mondjad ezt így
magyarul. Ilyen borzongás. Igen, ezzel
nagyon jó szó. borzongást éreztek az
emberek. És képzeld el, hogy
megfigyelték azt, hogy amikor a verseket
hallgatták, akkor felfigyeltek egy egy
olyan dologra, ami nincsen például a
zenénél vagy a prózánál. És ez a
prechilnek nevezték el ők ezt a
folyamatot, és ez arról szól, hogy
körülbelül 4,5 másodperccel hamarabb már
megjelent a bőrükön, illetve ezen a
gépen kimutatta a az a mérőeszköz, hogy
már egy ilyen izgalmi állapotba
kerültek. négy-öt másodperc azelőtt,
hogy ők megnyomták a gombot, és akkor
azt mondták, vagy ezt mutatták ki, hogy
ez egy picit olyan egy olyan, mint
amikor nyitasz ki egy ahhoz
hasonlították, mint amikor egy csokit
nyit nyitasz ki jó lassan. Igen. És már
érzed magadba azt a megajándékozom
magam izgalmat, hogy végre az a csoki az
enyém lesz. És hogy ehhez hasonló
például csak versolvasás, a költészet
hallgatása és olvasása közben
jön elő bennünk. És azt is kimutatták,
hogy
általában a a hallgatók és a költők a
akik olvasták, mindig a szakaszok vége
fele jött ez az izgalom, illetve az
egész versnek a vége fele. És ez ez
valószínűleg onnan jön, hogy ha több
verset olvasunk, akkor látjuk, hogy
mindig a végén derül ki, vagy hogy ott
van mindig egy ilyen
egy ilyen szentencia, vagy egy ilyen
lényeg kimondva.
Úgyhogy ez ez például egy nagyon érdekes
dolog, és rengeteg más olyan pozitív
hatása van az irodalomnak, a
költészetnek.
csökkenti a magányt, nemesíti a lelket,
tehát hogy csak egy párat soroljak fel,
a szorongást a depresszió
megelőzésében nagyon nagy mértékben
használják, például az
irodalomterapeuták. Szóval nincs amiért
ne ne éljünk vele. Mitől lesz egy vers?
Jó vers
szerinted? Vagy meg amikor elolvasol egy
verset, akkor meg tudod mondani, hogy
hát ez egy közepesi minőségű vers volt,
vagy ez egy gyenge vers volt? Ez egy egy
nagyon jó vers. Szerintem itt kicsit
külön kell választanunk azt, hogyha a
terápiás jelleggel nézzük, akkor
szerintem bármelyik vers lehet jó, mert
lehet, hogy
téged pont akkor az szólít meg. De
ugyanígy, hogyha megnézünk egy költőt,
akkor több költőnél is vannak ilyen
pályaelei versek, amiket ők akár később
meg is tagadnak. viszont abban a
korszakukban azt kellett kiírniuk
magukból, és vannak persze olyan diákok,
akik abban a korszakban vannak, és azt
kell elolvasniuk. Úgyhogy én azt
mondanám,
hogy nyilván ez mondjuk így így
színészként meg az, hogy van egy egy
igényességed, sok mindennek ellentmond,
de de de hogy vannak költők, akiket nagy
költőnek tartunk, és vannak akik nagyobb
hatással voltak a a magyar nyelvre és és
a kultúránkra, és vannak költők, akiket
nem is ismerünk. Tehát, hogy vannak
akkor ezek szerint van egy belső
hierarchia. Ez a Igen, te is olvastad
biztos a Barabási Albert László könyvét,
amiben a sikernek az egyik összetevője
az az pont ez, hogy hogy valahogy muszáj
eljuttasd magad emberekhez, mert a
kapcsolati hálód lesz az, aki egy újabb
újabbat emel rajtad ahhoz, hogy te
sikeres legyél. És ilyen szempontból
bizony vannak tévutak is. Tehát vannak
olyan költők, akik sokkal nagyobb
pályára lettek volna hivatottak, de
sosem jutottak el oda. Bár ha
összehasonlítjuk őket egy másik ismert
költőnek, vagyis a munkásságukat, akkor
azt látjuk, hogy ez is van legalább
annyira jó, de sajnos valamiért nem jó
helyen voltak, nem jókor voltak jó
helyen. Nem volt olyan a kapcsolati
hálójuk, nem fiatalon, mert ugye az is
fontos, hogy fiatalon üsd meg ezeket a
apropó, kérdezted ezt, hogy mi elmentünk
és hogy fiatalon lettem anya a színészi
pályámra, milyen hatással volt? Tehát
talán ez az egyetlen, ami ami ilyen
tehát, hogy úgy úgy azt éreztem, hogy
akkor úgy
fiatalon ide nekem az oroszlánt is, de
de mondjuk most is érzem ezt, úgyhogy
gondolom nem lehet éppen akkora baj. Na,
bocsánat, de hogy
visszatérve igen, van ebben
felelőssége az irodalomtudománynak is,
van ebben felelőssége az irodalom
tanárainknak is. És azt gondolom, hogy
de mondom az ellenkezője azért nem igaz.
Tehát az ellenkezője az az, hogy ha
valaki híres költővé vált, attól nem
véletlenül vált híres költővé. Tehát nem
az van, hogy hogy mindenki téved és
felszavazzuk Petőfit valamiért, vagy
vagy nem tudom, akárki más, hogy ilettás
költők nincsenek annyira, vagy nem
maradtak meg legalább is. Igen,
gyanítom, hogy kiszűrné a egyik
generáció magából, hogyha ha tényleg nem
lenne értékes az, amit csinál.
Igen, inkább olyanok vannak szerintem,
hogy valami
miatt cikizzük őket, vagy akár az
életkörülményeik, vagy akár mit mondjak.
Tehát, hogy most, hogyha egy példát
akarok hozni neked, akkor mondjuk Vas
Albert nem egy egy elit
irodalmárnak számít a a nagykörökben. De
én ezzel abszolút nem mondom azt, hogy
nagyon szereti az erdélyi ember olvasni
Vasalbertet és ne teggye. Tehát, hogy
hogy erre mondtam azt, hogy hogy
szerintem a a helyénk kell a dolgokat
mindig kezelni és
és
tudni azt, hogy el kell olvasni egy
ilyet, de el kell olvasni egy
mit mondjak most, kit hozzak neked fel?
egy egy másfajta irodalmi művet is.
Igen. A másik problémám, ami személyesen
engem meggátol abban, hogy hogy tehát
olvasgattam verseket, de én mindig a
nagy ágyukat próbáltam olvasni, amiatt
kevés időn van. És akkor arra gondoltam,
hogy ha már kevés időm van, akkor
próbálják meg a lehető legjobb versekből
válogatni, hogy ha tegyük fel 20 verset
tudok el ololvasni, akkor a 20 legjobbat
olvassam. viszont az az érzésem, hogy
bizonyos szempontból kapufa, mert a 20
legnagyobb vers annyira komplex, annyira
nem nem
hiába vált azzá, hogy hogy pont nem
tudom megszeretni a verseket. Olyan,
mintogyha a legnehezebb könyvekkel
próbálkoznék pont így. És gyakorlatilag
végtelen mennyiségű vers van. Tehát
annyi időm nekem sosem lesz, hogyha
egész életemben verseket is olvasnék,
hogy hogy eligazodjak ebbe a a ez ebbe a
versóceánba, ami előttem van. Úgyhogy
mit tanácsolnál nekem, aki küzdök ezzel,
és gyanítom, hogy a hallgatók közül
nagyon sokan küzdenek ezzel, hogy hol
fogjanak neki verset olvasni, hogy
egyrészt ne unják meg, másrészt pedig,
hogy hogy mégis azért azért jó verseket
olvassanak? Mit mi jó vers? Ezért is
kérdeztem. Én azt mondanám, például
említetted itt a láthatatlan munkát, és
így eszembe jutott, hogy milyen jó lett
volna, amikor én is azt éltem meg, hogy
csak otthon, csak otthon. Ha találkozom
mondjuk a Turi Timeának, aki egy
kortársköltőnő a Dallas Láthatatlan
Munkáról című versével, ami a nőnapi
előadásomban is benne volt, és látni a
nők arcát, ahogy pontosan tudtuk, hogy
miről beszél ebben a versben, és azt
érezni, hogy őket már megfogtuk ezzel a
verssel már megfogtam, mert tudtak
csatlakozni, tudtak kapcsolódni ehhez a
dologhoz. És én azt javasolnám, hogy
mindenképp olyannal kezdjük, ami minket
érdekel, amihez tudunk csatlakozni.
Ezért gondolom azt, hogy egy picit jó
lenne másképp más helyről megközelíteni.
Tehát ahogy pont te voltál az, aki a
TEDxes, az első TEDExes fellépésem után
rámírtál, hogy mentél az ANAFRA és
eszedbe jutott
a vers, amit vittem én a az ANAFAL
kapcsolatban, és akkor azt éreztem, hogy
vow, tehát hogyha ennyit értem el én,
hogy egy embernek a a közönségből egy
vers eszébe jutott az ANAFról, akkor én
már elvégeztem a dolgomat. Igen. És és
ugyanígy a a gyerekekkel is, hogyha
annyit értem el, hogy amikor
dacoskodtak, és mondtam nekik, hogy van
ez a kicsike medve, akinek dacos a
kedve, egy varrodani verset, vagy hogy
ők
megtanulták, akkor akkor már
beleültettem egy csírát,
amiből adott esetben kikelhet az, hogy
ők versolvasók lesznek, mert ahogy
mondtam, 10 éves korunkig ezzel így
foglalkozunk, de
A családnak köszönhetően, az oktatásnak
köszönhetően, még úgy 10-től 18 éves
korunkig, akár a kötelezők miatt is
olvasunk verset, 18 éves korunk után a
legtöbben elengedjük a versolvasást.
De akkor, hogyha mi megmutatjuk 18 éves
korukig a gyerekeknek, hogy a
versolvasás izgi. A versolvasás az egy
kortárs dolog, egy vagány dolog,
legalább annyira vagány, mint a
Facebook, mint a TikTok, mint a a nem
tudom, a Messenger, a akkor akkor ez be
fog épülni az ő életükbe. És és és ha
nem másra slam
poetryvel,
kortársköltőkkel rávezetjük őket arra,
hogy ez jó, akkor akkor nem fogjuk
elveszíteni. A slemet is akkor ide
sorolod a versek közé. Igen, én
szerintem fontos az, mivel én hiszek
abban, hogy a a művészetről nem lehet
rég
régi ideje múlt módon gondolkodni, ezért
azt gondolom, hogy hogy igen. A Slam
poetry az volt a az egyik olyan dolog,
ami ami segített abban, hogy ne érezzük
azt, hogy a költészet haldoklik.
Tehát, hogy gondolj bele abba, hogy
ameddig még régen nagyanyáink könyves
polcát végignézted, és az Adi összes,
Petőfi összes, a Tót Árpád satöbbi,
mindenki minden ott volt. Addig
a amiután bejött az internet és a média
világa, a könyvek már maradtak a polcon,
és mindenki a gépeken meg a telefonját
nyomogatja. Na most akkor ezzel mit
tudunk csinálni?
Próbáljuk őket rávenni. Tedd le a
telefont, vedd le a poros könyvet. Ez is
egy módszer. Szerintem nem annyira
hatékony, mint az, hogy alkalmazkodni és
a a telefonba betenni a verseket, az
életébe becsempészni a verseket. Amíg
várja a buszt, legyen ott egy vers.
Tudjon elolvasni egy verset. Ahogy lejön
a patkóba, ez volt az egyik
gondolat. Vagy legyen, ahová elvigye a
szerelmét Bálint napon. Miért ne lehet
az egy programpont, hogy elmegyünk és
egy Vörös Rózsa mellett elolvasunk 10
verset is, ami
kortárs, klasszikus,
bármi, és valahogy ebben hiszek, hogy
megtalálni ezeket a
módozatokat, ahogy tud tudunk szólni,
arra gondoltam, hogy miért ne
szentelhetnék egy kicsi időt arra, hogy
hintsünk el pár magot. Most azt mondtad,
hogy a vers mindenkinek szól, és minden
élethelyzetre van egy vers. Úgyhogy
megkérnélek,
hogy pár élethelyzetet válasszunk ki, és
hozzunk rá így egy verset. Mit szólsz
hozzá? Jó, mehet. Igen. A az egyik, amit
ami ami kezdjük egy egyszerűvel, vagyis
nem tudom, mit jelent az egyszerű, de
kezdjük az örömmel, ami
pozitívum. Tudnál egy olyan verset
felolvasni nekünk, amelyik amelyik ezt
az örömöt fejezi ki?
Itt elsőként a ilyen általános iskolás
vers jutott az eszembe, aminek azért
örültem, mert ahogy említettem az előbb,
hogyha egy verset elolvasunk, és lehet,
hogy nem törődünk akkor vele, de az a
belső könyves polcunkban ott marad. És
amikor mondhat, hogy akár az örömről
valamit, akkor ez így eszembe jutott.
Úgyhogy ezt hoztam el. Valamennyire
valamennyire emlékszem is egyébként erre
a versre.
De mert meg kellett tanulnunk, és itt
visszatérnék oda, hogy milyen nagy
felelőssége van a pedagógusoknak abban,
hogy mi versolvasók legyünk. Nekem a
tanítónén elég sok verset tanított meg,
meg akár édesanyám, majd a későbbi
irodalomtanárnőm is. És akkor az áprili
vers így hangzik:
ember, ne félj, nő már a nap. A jégfogú
szél nem harap, a koldus is dúdolva jár.
Ragyog rongyán a napsugár. A gond sem él
mindig ne hidd. Ragad meg és a hóra
vitt. A hóval szétfoszlik hamar. Elmossa
egy langyos
vihar. A déli szél kürtyébe fú.
Léggömbel játszik egy fiú. Most
elszakadt a gömzsinek, s a gömbje
boldogan lebeg. ringatja a tavasszele.
Szállj fel, kedvem, szállj fel
vele. Ez volt a a az igazság, hogy
teljesen másképp hallgattam, mint
emlékszem erre a versre, amikor
tanultok. Most teljesen más volt.
Teljesen más volt, mert benne volt az,
hogy hogy az ember életében helye van a
a szomorúságnak is, de az
elmúlik. Na, nagyon jó. És és ez látod,
hogy hogy a vers egy-egy ilyen kicsi
momentuma az életed különböző
szakaszaiban másképp is szólhat. Tehát
van olyan, most akár megkérdezték tőlem,
hogy mi a kedvenc versem így a a
költészet napjával kapcsolatban, és nem
tudom egyre ráfogni, hogy ez a kedvenc
versem. ugyanis a különböző
életszakaszaimban különböző versek
találnak meg, és mindig az aktuális, az
ami ami akkor izgat, amiben akkor érzem
azt, hogy valami van, ami a mai
napsütést más napsütéssé teszi, mint a
tegnapi. Mi hogy döntöd el, hogy milyen
verses kötetet veszel a kezedbe?
Ebben van egy pici tudatosság is, tehát
pont amiatt, amit mondtam neked, én
nagyon törekszem arra, hogy a
kortársakkal tartsam a a tempót, és
ennek egy példája akár a verselőpodcast
is, de mindig megvásárolom azt, hogyha
van most például diákoknak kiadott
direkt mondjuk szerelemről szóló
verseskötet, és és akkor azt gondolom,
hogy mindig mindig azt is akarom látni.
És akkor ezt úgy olvasod el, mint egy
könyvet, hogy az első oldalt elkezded,
és akkor végigolvasod a végéig, vagy
pedig randomra kinyitod? Randomra
kinyitom, de jellemző az, hogyha
készülök valamire, akkor általában
sokszor használok verseket, és akkor az
adott témával kapcsolatban keresgélek.
És akkor például akár a nőnapi, a
legutóbbi nőnapi műsorom kapcsán tudtam
azt, hogy a női létnek az állomásait
járom végig, és hogy ezt magamnak
felírtam, hogy mik ezek az állomások. És
akkor már tudatosan kerestem verset
arra, hogy szülésélmény mondjuk, vagy
verset arra, hogy vagy szöveget arra,
hogy nem jön össze a gyerek, vagy
szöveget a akár a láthatatlan munkáról,
és és akkor akkor megvan, hogy mit
keresek.
A most már muszáj megkérdezem ezt is,
hogy nagyon sokat foglalkozok a
mesterséges intelligenciával, meg a a
ennek inkább a a pszichológiai
vetületével, meg a filozófiai
vetületével, hogy állítólag én amúgy nem
láttam, de az állítólag a a az AI is tud
most már jó verseket írni. Én mindig
pocsékverseket láttam, nem rimeltek, nem
volt semmilyen tartalma. Ez lehet, hogy
valami mélyen emberi dolog ez a
versírás, valami olyan, amit
valószínűleg nem fog tudni az AI
lemásolni, mert mindig egy másolat lesz,
mindig egy unalmas valami lesz. Te hogy
próbáltál ilyesmit? Próbáltam, igen. És
nekem amúgy teljesen jó tapasztalatom
volt, sőt néhol ijesztő tapasztalat is.
Pont a azt hiszem a tavalyi digitális
skalákára készültem egy ilyen verssel,
amit direkt megkértem, hogy az AI
mondjon fel. Sőt, még megspékeltem
azzal, hogy a hangomat beadtam neki, és
úgy kértem, hogy az én hangomon mondassa
ezt fel, és ijesztő volt. Akkor még
annyira a felmondó jellege nem volt
annyira jó. azt most már azóta még
tökéletesítette azt a részt, de
hogy megvolt, megírta, rímelt, rendben
volt. Valami kicsi lélek hiányzott
belőle, és én abban reménykedem, hogy ez
a lélek az, amit nem fognak.
Tehát, hogy azt nem látom magam előtt,
ahogy egy AI szöveg hallatán embereknek
a
szeméből szemében megjelenik a könycsep,
vagy ez a chilsz, amiről beszéltünk, a
libabőr, azt egyelőre nem látom. Lehet,
hogy el fogunk odajutni, de én emiatt
bízom abban, hogy az emberi tényező az
még
mindig sokat nyomalatba. Én valahol
remélem, hogy sosem fog ez eljönni. Nem,
szerintem sem,
de tény, hogy nagyon jó úton halad az
AI. Most nemrég valamit éppen csináltam
ott a a chat GPT-vel beszélgettem, és
lejött Gergő körülbelül ötször elmondta,
hogy menjek és hozzak le neki
egy labdát és mondtam, hogy kicsi Gergő,
menjél és hozz le és akkor labdázunk. és
poénból mondta nekem, hogy anya, írd be,
hogy hozz ecset GPT. És beírtam neki,
csak úgy kíváncsiságból, hogy Gergő
kéri, hogy hozz le a labdát a
szobájából, és ezt írta vissza:
"Rendben, máris
hozom. Hogyha ez egy belső poén, akkor
üzenem Gergőnek, hogy nagyon vicces, de
nem tudom, mit térjünk vissza." És így
maradtunk, mert vette a lapot. Tehát,
hogy azért amiről azt gondolnánk, hogy a
humor egy emberi kvalitás, egy egy
emberi
specifikum, azt egy gép simán azt
észlelte, hogy ez egy vicc, és ő reagált
viccesen rá. Tehát, hogy ez már
félelmetes, de de ahogy említetted azt,
hogy jöttél ki előadásról, úgy a
drognaplóról,
én azt gondolom, hogy hogy azt a azt a
plusz testbeszédet, amit
említettél, azt például homonoid
homonoid robotok nem fogják átadni. Nem,
nem fogják tudni azt átadni. És ugye
beszéltünk erről, hogy hogy milyen
sokkal fontosabb a nonverbális
kommunikáció, mint a szavaink ereje,
vagy a szavaknak a a pár százaléka.
Igen. És hogy sokkal többet adunk mi
emberként arra, amit látunk, amit amit
amit kapunk a metakommunikációval.
Én azt gondolom, hogy emiatt nincsen a
művészetnek en ez a területe
veszélyben, mert emberek vagyunk, és
mindig arra leszünk kíváncsiak, az
emberi sérelmekre, az
emberi bánatra, az emberi életnek a
különböző kudarcaira és arra, hogy ezt
hogy élik meg az embertársaink. Erre len
versjában, hogy az emberi sérelmekre, a
frusztráltságra, a bánatra van egy
versed, amit Van egy hát van akár a ez a
ez a Varró Dani vers, de ez amúgy egy
gyerekvers, de a a női előadásom kapcsán
a frusztráltságról,
illetve arról, hogy mindenki elégedetlen
önmagával, arról hoztam el egy verset,
Harkasára verse, Fogyókúra.
Ideje leadnom az évek alatt rám rakódott
súlyt, megszabadulni a feleslegtől, hogy
pehelykönnyűnek érezzem magam.
Tündöklőbb formámba kerüljek, úgyhogy
állhatatosan edzek, napról napra
alakítom magam, és leadok más5él kgó
másoknak megfelelést. Fogyok 5 cm a túl
nagy combomból, leizzadok magamból 10 d
teljesítenem kellt. Leadok 4 kg
szorongató emléket olyan helyekről, ahol
nem is tudtam, hogy súlyokat tárolok.
Lefogyok. kiló majd alkalmazkodok ott.
Ellenben felszedek magamra 100 g fontos
vagyok ott. Elengedek 20 kg ellenem
vétett bűnt, szélnek keresztek kilenc
különféle tartozást, karcsusodom az
önostorozásban, leizzadom a maradjak
csendbent, és hízok helyette kicsit a
hangszálaimra. Leadom az egykori alakom
utáni
sóvárgást, és kidobom a mérlegemet.
Mióta napról napraódik az alakom, muszáj
lecserélnem a
ruhatáramat. Letekerem a nyakamról a
fullasztó emberek sájait. Lerázom a
vállamról az irigyek hangjának
boleróját. Ellenben felmerem venni a nem
álljol nadrágot. Kiürítem a zsebemből a
vásárlással vígasztalódó tárcámat.
Elengedem az ajándékba kapott, de sosem
szeretett holmikat. Kevesebbet hordom a
sikereimet, zsugorító szemüveget.
Elajándékozom a hátha valahogy
belefogyok szoknyákat. Lecserélem a
berögzött, tanult bakancsot egy saját
kezem által formált, pont
rámilleszkedő rózsaszín szandálra.
Nagyon jó.
Ez szerintem ez is egy olyan
kortársszöveg, amiben
amiben irgalmatlan mennyiségű
frusztráltság van,
beletéve és és valahogy mutat egy egy
olyan más
perspektívába, ami amiről az jön le,
hogy és mi van, hogyha ezeket
elengedjük?
Igen. Tehát én abszolút átéreztem ebbe
azt a fajta életutat, amikor ami amit én
is bejártam meg a feleségemmel együtt,
hogy elindulunk abból a fajta
sztereotípképből, hogy hogyan kell
kinézzünk, és küzdünk küzdünk megfelelni
neki,
és ezzel lassan belefáradunk ebbe a
küzdésbe, és utána pedig elkezdünk
átalakulni és egy újabb életszakaszba
lépni, és ez, hogy ezt leírta valaki,
összeköt azzal a személlyel. És az, hogy
te is bólogatsz, azt jelenti, hogy
számodra nem véletlenül választottad ki
számodra is ez egy jó vers.
Úgyhogy úgyhogy nagyon sokan küzdenek
ugyanezzel. A nők 90%-a elégedetlen
magával és nem tudna felsorolni, vagy
maxim maximum egy dolgot tud felsorolni,
ami ami tetszik önmagán. És ez is
szerintem egy egy olyan példa, hogyha
kényszerítünk nőket, hogy olvassanak
bármilyen régi verset a
nőiségről, akkor elolvassák, de nem
tudnak kapcsolódni. nem tudnak
kapcsolódni vele, és ha valakit meg
tudsz fogni egy ilyennel, mert ő is ezt
éli nap mint nap, akkor én hiszem, hogy
utána hazamegy, és nem csak hiszem,
hanem tapasztalom is. Tehát konkrétan a
női előadásom kapcsán többen kerestek
meg Facebookon, és írtak rám, hogy
elkérhetnék-e ezt vagy azt a szöveget,
vagy nem emlékeznek, hogy az miről
szólt, és hogy nagyon megérintette őket.
És én azt hiszem, hogy így érdemes
művészetről, így érdemes költészetről,
irodalomról, bármiről beszélni, hogyha
hogyha azzal valamit akarunk adni a
másiknak. Tehát hogyha azt akarjuk, hogy
tényleg a küküllő megint kezdjen el
folyni lefele, vagy induljon el jobban,
ha van valami valami plusz célunk vele.
Az anyasággal kapcsolatban van-e versed?
Igen, az anyasággal kapcsolatban egy
érdekes verset hoztam, ugyanis ez
összeköti az én anyaságomat és az én
lányságomat is. Ugyanis ezt a verset
édesanyám választotta a
lánykikérésemre, és amikor ott volt a
nagy násznép,
akkor az unokatestvéremet kérte meg, és
ő olvasta ezt fel. És én ezt betettem a
nőnapi előadásomba is, mert nagyon
meghatározó és nagyon érdekes az, hogy
elég ritkán sikerül úgy végigolvasni,
hogy közben én is ne annára gondoljak és
ne érzékenyüljek el. Úgyhogy most egyet
próbálkozom színészként sztereotipikusan
megnyilvánulni.
Ornella Fiorini
lányomnak nagy szárnyakat szeretnék adni
neked, hogy szállj erőseket, mint a
karvajé, hogy a szabadság magasságában
könnyű szárnyalással lebegni tudj, és
siklani az élet színein át. A csendben
meghallani a szelet, és minden szót,
melyből mesék születnek.
Emlékezz erre, és élvezd a repülést a
tenger felett, a fűszálakon át, sőt,
miért is ne, akár széttépett álmok
között, mert
mindennek, még a zuzmara jegének is
értelme
van. Erős szárnyakat szeretnék adni
neked, hogy leküzd a távolságot, a port,
mely a szívedet szorítja, és mindazt, mi
aranynak látszik, és amely valójában nem
az.
Nagy szárnyakat szeretnék adni neked,
sűrű pejheset, hogy megóvjon, ha
elvétenéd a repted, és ha le is zuhansz,
ne essen
bajod. Íme hát a szárnyak, melyeket adni
szeretnék
neked, de nem
lehet, mert csak te vagy, ki magadnak
őket
megteremtheted. És sikerült. Nem, nem.
belebőgni.
Azért megremegedett a hangod egy
pillanat? Igen, a végén. Igen, de
próbáltam.
De figyelj, emlékszem, hogy az egyik
legfontosabb dolog, amit megértettem
filozófiai
szempontból, az pont akkor volt, amikor
miközben mondta az a valaki, elcsuklott
a hangja, és éreztem, hogy ott most
valamire kell figyelni. Nem értettem
magát intellektuálisan azt a szöveget,
de vagy 20-szor visszahallgattam magát
az előadást, és és a 20-ra esett le,
hogy te jóik, tehát egy új keretrendszer
kezdett felépülni a fejemben, egy új
világ, ami amiből azóta is profitálok én
és a
közösségem, és ha nem lett volna az
érzelmi töltete, akkor nem
tulajdonítanék neki elég elég súlyt.
Nálunk a színházban van egy olyan
szabály, vagy nem tudom, nem szabály, de
hogy valahogy azt kell elérni, hogy ne
én sírjak, hanem te sírjál.
És persze vannak vannak olyan olyan
helyzetek, amikor nem baj az, hogyha az
ember elérzékenyül, de de kvázi mindig
inkább erre kell törekedni, hogy
valahogy úgy megérinteni a nézőt, hogy
ne téged sajnáljon, ne azt lássa, hogy
te magadat sajnálod, hanem hanem te
mindig tudjál egy picit távol maradni a
szövegtől. Mondjuk egy versolvasásra ez
nem érvényes, gondolom. miközben olvasod
a verset, nem kell úgy olvasni,
mintogyha te egy távoli valaki lennél a
hőyt, te nem vagy benne. Nem, nem, hát
ebben is nyilván, mint minden másban, az
életben iskolák vannak. Latinovic Zoltán
volt az, aki aki aki szakított az addigi
hagyományokkal, ami ugye úgy volt, hogy
egy verset mindig ilyen fennkölten,
patetikusan, deáló stílusban kell
előadni. És akkor ő mondta azt, hogy a
verset mondjuk. Tehát a verset pont úgy
mondom, elbeszélem, mintha a hétköznapi
életben veled beszélgetnék. És fontosnak
látta ő azt, hogy a a színész az mindig
helyezkedjen bele ebbe, és élje meg
azokat az érzéseket.
És én is azt hiszem, hogy valahol
valahol így szeretek verset mondani.
Tehát, hogy én is hiszek abban, hogyha
ez rajtam átmegy, akkor átmegy a a
közönségen is, mélyebben megy át a
közönségemen, hogyha én is mélyebben
élem meg, de de azért mindig mindig
mondjuk ez így cél, hogy hogy ne ne az
legyen, hogy akkor én végig bőgöm,
hogyha olyan a téma. Nekem most adott
abszolút az, hogy éreztem, hogy te benne
vagy ebbe a ezek ezekbe a sorokba benne
vagy, áttéled és és adott. És valójában
ami ami ebbe a versbe számomra bele volt
kódolva, az az a szülői féltés, ahogyan
tekintünk a gyermekeinkre. És újra és
újra, ha végiggondoljuk, rájövünk arra,
hogy nem tudjuk megvédeni direktbe a
gyermekeinket, hanem indirektbe tudjuk
azt, hogy olyan szárnyakat adunk nekik,
amiket ők akarnak majd magunknak
kinöveszteni. És és apropó érzelmi
biztonság, mert számomra például a
szárnyak az, hogy Igen. hogy hogy ott
vagy, megadod neki, hogy akarjon
elrepülni.
Igen, ez ez nagyon fájdalmas, mert sokat
gondoltam arra, hogyan tudom én
megvédeni a lányaimat, és rájöttem arra,
hogy direktbe én nem fogom tudni
megvédeni őket soha. Tehát nagyon kevés
az a lehetőség, hogy én most így
hősapakként bemegyek és szétverek
mindent. annak voltak ilyen főleg amikor
ilyen kisbabák voltak ilyen amikor hogy
is nevezik daydream amikor így
elkalandozik a a a gondolatom és úgy
akkor ilyenkor elképzel mindenféle
hőstettet amit majd véghez viszek hogy
megvédjem ezt a kicsi csöbbséget és
rájövök arra ja rájöttem arra amután
magamhoz tértem hogy ez ez nem így
működik tehát úgy tudom megvédeni hogyha
én olyan férfivá válok és olyan apává
válok akit majd ők is keresni fognak és
ezáltal tudom én megvédeni őt
Úgyhogy ez mind bele volt kódolva ebbe
számomra ez a számomra nag úgyhogy
köszönöm szépen tényleg alakítasz
alakítasz engem és remélem hogy a
hallgatókat is azáltal hogy hogyan
viszonyuljak a versekhez mert épp mond
amúgy ilyen
verssérült vagyok a aki középiskolából
úgy jött el hogy hogy csak verseket ne
halljak és aztán persze időközben volt
egy-egy ugyan ahogy mondtad néha
felbukkant az életemben egy-egy sorah
ahol nem tudom, hogy honnan bukkant fel,
de például a parlament mellett
Magyarországon Pesten, amikor ott van a
József Attila szobor, valami megindít.
És akkor olyankor elővettem egy-egy
József Attila verset, és én magamra se
ismertem ilyenkor, hogy én én itt sem
elén.
Szóval szóval igen. Írtál verseket is?
Írtam verseket én is szerintem úgy 10
éves korom alatt, tehát hogy úgy-es
koromra emlékszem.
volt, tehát hogy például nyertem is
ilyen versíró meg meseíró pályázatokon.
Talán van egy könyv is, amiben nem
emlékszem pontosan, hogy abban azt
hiszem, hogy a mesém jelent meg, és nem
a versem, de úgy úgy úgy számomra mindig
az irodalom az egy picit több volt, mint
mint olvasni. Sajnos ez a ez a mai
életemből kikopott teljesen. Tehát
szerintem utoljára még a mivel sokat
voltunk távkapcsolatban, volt egy ilyen
naplónk, ami innen odajárt a férjemmel,
és akkor azt hiszem, hogy abban
írogattam. Igen. Van-e egy olyan vers,
ami most ebben a pillanatban, hogy
olyan, mintogyha egy saját krédód lenne,
hogy magad, mintogyha a te küldetésedről
szólna, hogy hogy te ki lehetnél, vagy
ki is kéne legyél? Van egy ilyen versy,
ami ami most neked szól? Fodor Sándor,
nem, Fodor Ákost nagyon szeretem. Ő
ilyen rövid létösszegző haikukat szokott
írni, és tőle van jó pár olyan vers,
amit amit
szeretek. Az egyik az a kínálat, ami így
hangzik, hogy van fénynyelő arc és van
fényvisszaverő. Válasz, választhatsz.
Ez az egyik, ami ami azt hiszem, hogy
ilyen hitvallásom, hogy hogy mindegy.
Beszéljünk egy kicsit róla, kicsit
kibontod nekem, hogy ez miről szól
számodra,
hogy van van olyan Igen, hogy valamivel
jövünk a világra
mindannyian, amit amit kaptunk fentről.
Tehát hogyha most a költészetre akarom
ezt nagyon visszahúzni, mert erről
beszéltünk, akkor régen az ókori görögök
is azt mondták, hogy az istenektől
kapják a tudást a
költők. És
de akár hogyha a mondjuk a Bibliára
gondolok, akkor Akinisz Tamás is azt
mondja, hogy a a művész, a művészetét,
az alkotásra való hajlamát, azt az
isteni
ajándékként kapja. És és én azt
gondolom, hogy minden ember úgy jön a
világra, hogy valami pluszot kap, valami
csomagot, amiben ő több, és hogy ezt a
csomagot megtartja-e magának, vagyis
fényelő lesz-e azt a fényt, amit kapott,
megtartja magának, elnyeli, kész, vagy
vagy visszaveri és azt gondolja,
hogy ezt ebből többet tudok csinálni, ha
ki odaadom másoknak
is. Ez szerintem valójában az élet,
tehát ez egy nagyon nagyon evidens dolog
az életünkben is tényleg így van, hogy
ezt eldönthetjük. Az, hogy mi az
életünket milyen emberként éljük, simán
eldöntheti mindenki, akármelyik
életkorában. eldöntheti 10 évesen, de
eldöntheti 60 évesen
is. És
én ezt ezt így a magam énak tehát az,
ami lesüt rólad, az a az, amiért az
emberek dicsérnek téged, az ami ami
vonzó benned, az az a fény, ami nem
belőled árad, hanem lesüt rólad,
visszavered. Én nem másokkal
kapcsolatban fogalmaznám ezt meg. Tehát
nem az, hogy hogy dicsérnek vagy mások
hogy látnak, hanem ez egy belső döntés
kérdése, hogy te akarsz adni,
akarsz fényvisszaverő lenni, aki de hogy
benne van, hogy nem a saját fényed?
Ha ha valamit visszaversz, azt jelenti,
hogy hogy
valami, hogy az igazi fény forrása nem
te vagy. Hát igen, de szerintem minden
minden tulajdonságunknak valahol van egy
egy alapja, amivel
születünk. Tehát hogyha én most itt
gondoltam arra, hogy mindenki egyfajta
tehetséggel jön a világra. Tehát erre
gondolok, ez a fény. Nyilván azt a fényt
kell ápolni, kell csiszolni. Mert ha nem
akkor végül is elnyelődik, hogyha te
nem, ha te csak azt beengeded, és nem
fejleszted tovább, hogy tud vissza
vissza tükrözni az emberekre. De hogy
hogy ilyen szempontból valójában nekem
fontos az, hogy én én melyik melyik
akarok lenni, és nem azért, hogy holnap
azt mondják rólam az
emberek, hogy és hirtelen eszembe jutott
ez a a zsida ilyenővers, ami
a a
halotti, hogy mondják, a sírversre, hogy
megtettem mindent, amit megtehettem,
kinek tartoztam, mindent megfizettem.
elengedem mindenki tartozását, és
felejtsd el arcom romló földi mását. És
és ez jutott eszembe, hogy hogy milyen
földi, milyen arcról marad meg. Nem ez
érdekel, hogy az emberek mit, hanem hogy
én belülről Igen. Tehát, hogy én
belülről mit élek meg, hogy én a
társadalomnak egy hasznos tagja voltam,
ez nem annyira jó szó rá, vagy vagy úgy
ott voltam én is. És és én azt érzem,
hogy a művészetnek a
közvetítésével azzal, hogyha néha meg
tudom embereknek mutatni, hogy hogy
mennyi potenciál van benne, és hogy hogy
ők maguk mennyit tudnának belőle
gyarapodni. Én én azt gondolom, hogy ez
az, amivel én esetleg tudok fényt
ide-oda vinni, vagy fényt visszaverni.
És azért érzem, hogy ez egy picit egy
ilyen létösszegző vers, vagy egy olyan
vers, ami ami lehet az én hitvallásom.
Mit hoztál más verset is? Igen. Hát
látod, egy érdekes amúgy a a második
először ez jutott eszembe, azaz este
ugyancsak Fodor Ákostól, ami szintén
erről szól. Visszasugárzom, amit kaptam,
mint a kő a napmelegét.
És akkor a harmadik az a summa vagy
szumma. Minden megérint, úgy látszik
sose nő be a szívem lágya.
Szóval Fodor Ákos az, akit egyébként
nagyon ajánlok, hogy hogy olvasson
mindenki. Tehát látod, három sor, minden
nap van ideje mindenkinek három sort
elolvasni,
és és lehet, hogy elolvasod reggel, és
így egész nap ezen fogsz kattogni, hogy
ez mit is jelent.
Azt hiszem, ez a
legtökéletesebb zárszó. Köszönöm szépen,
hogy eljöttél. Én is köszönöm. Tanultam
most is. És és Fodorákost fogok olvasni
egy kicsit. Hét percet. Igen, napi hét
percet 30 napig. Köszönöm szépen.
Köszönöm én is. Ha tetszett ez a műsor,
akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a
csatornánkra. Ezzel tudsz támogatni
minket. Köszönjük a Week kávé
közösségnek a jó kávéért, az ötvös
udvarnak a helyért, valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért.
Nélkületek nem jöhetett volna ez létre.